You again, also, just talking to other people and apparently
not really looking into like much of the footage enough to end
up having dog opinions, actual dog uninformed opinions. Oh, you
guys are anti-war about Iran now? How about shut the [__]
up and never speak again.
>> Hello. You, you. [music] Do you have an idea where you
want to start or should I just sort of like lay out whatever
my idea >> the question is why do you think there's anything
close to a unifying force that or any movement that could like
actually facilitate some sort of popular
>> Right, right, right. Got you. So, I mean everyone obviously
understand I'm doing I'm reading tea leaves here, right? This
is This is my schizo post and we'll see in a few months if I'm
just completely or like a prophet or whatever the [__]
right? But, um
I got the impression that I felt confirmed Trump was going to
make the attack when I saw him very like verbatim quoting Lindsey
Graham on something and I was like he very much has this guy
in his ear, obviously. And, uh and his rhetoric has shifted to,
like I said, direct quotation. And, it's when he started talking
about regime change being the best option. And, the Lindsey Graham
connection is that he's like very, very close uh you guys can
laugh and call me a [__] by the way, I understand.
But, he's very, very close friends with the Reza Pahlavi guy
and he's been friends with him for like I think decades and whatever.
Very, very much like um he's kind of hand in hand with him, right?
So,
>> the the super optimistic, like this is idealism, I know,
but I I mean this happening in the first place feels uh feels
very idealistic in the first place or like uh whatever, one in
a million
the idealistic outcome is that
Pahlavi ends up being the transitionary like 100 days after plan
to like let people create their parties and have the referendum
and then run an election and move forward. >> gone to the
part where things are quelled, where there is like an uprising
that's stabilized. >> Yeah, yeah. Sorry, sorry. I meant
to I yeah, I mean I mean like walk through that. So, the Reza
Pahlavi what I'm trying to get to is that Reza Pahlavi has already
been leading like he has a whatever team of people that are in
whatever different fields like basically a kind of cabinet of
experts so that he can um prepare to walk in there and not just
be like, "All right, guys, where do we start?" Right? Like you
have to actually have some idea what's going on. And uh like
>> What's his plan to not be killed by the
>> That is a risk. That is absolutely a risk. Someone could
have And in fact, I would say people are going to try to >> No,
like like he's literally It would be like Osama bin Laden walking
into America and just being like, "I'm ready to take America
over." >> Oh, I mean obviously he can't go there until
this like uh you know imaginary best-case outcome where um the
they end up submitting and basically surrendering because the
US can bomb them into pure submission. It has to be that level
of destruction
of the IRGC and like the Well, if the military isn't they could
decide to move over move over and like actually just protect
the country and stop being a a [__] >> They're
not doing that. They are on like a holy mission holy mission
headed out of them by God. They're definitely not doing that.
>> that's that's the IRGC specifically. And some people
in the military are also surely super devout um Muslims in that
way or like fundamentalists extremists >> Well, and the
IRGC, I believe it's all devout fundamentalists. >> Yeah,
yeah. That's what I said. That's what I said. That's it. That's
Yeah, that's exactly what I said, right? So, the IRGC is 100%
like the fanatics. They're like the SS of the religion. And then
the military is like Surely there's people with similar beliefs
in there who just aren't on the same squad. But they're not as
bound to the
religious um leadership, basically, is what I'm saying, right?
And then there's the Basij militia, which is a whole other layer.
But all of them Basically, all of those oppressing forces have
to be bombed to the point of submission. That is the only way
you're going to get an environment where Reza Pahlavi can even
return to the country without just getting immediately blasted.
That is That is the condition.
>> So, how long do you think it will take to get there?
And how much do you think America's going to spend? >> Uh
so, that's obviously going to be hard for me to assess just because
it's like what kind of concept do I have of how war takes place
like time scale-wise. The hope is that it can be quick, but I
think it'll take a few weeks. >> don't just airstrike other
countries to take them over? Do you understand why that's not
a thing you can do? Yeah.
Okay, why? Cuz it takes more Okay, can you just Let's not do
the quiz thing. Just tell me what you want me to understand and
let's move forward.
What is it about it that you
So, it's basically
too expensive. You cannot bomb an opponent the size of Iran into
submission because it would cost
I I don't even know that you could
like you you would have to start using some other kind of munitions,
right? Like and it would start just you'd be shredding the Iranian
people, too. Like you you're never you're never going to bomb
the military the IRGC into submission because it's going to take
more munitions that you've brought with you. Okay, I'm I'm not
even trying to be an ass when I say that. On some level is
is an assumption of what can be accomplished with what we assume
they have in total. We are on some level assuming what you just
said, right?
In this case that they that they don't have enough munitions
to handle putting them into submission.
You use airstrikes and things like this these kinds of ordinance
to open up a room for your ground troops to move in that are
far cheaper. Yes. So, there is no boots on the ground effect
here. To try to bomb a country the size of Iran into submission
has literally never worked in in human history. And trust me,
there's like I just don't think unless you think these guys are
going like full on Kissinger on Iran, which then I would start
to go back to like do you really think they have the best interest
in the of the Iranian people at heart, right?
Like like they're not going to bomb that regime into submission
ever. And so, you This is the whole point is you basically would
need some equivalent of the boots up boots on the ground. Now,
in places where there can be a popular uprising, where it's like
everybody is against them, right? Um that that can uh that can
turn really easily when there's an actual popular uprising going
on. >> Cuz that provides you the boots on the ground even
if they don't have if they're not necessarily armed in the way
that the military is. >> that has been something that has
happened before where I believe the US has provided air support
to people, but those are like >> I'm glad you walked through
that point of this explanation. >> total destruction or
or disintegration of the government, right? >> Yeah, but
I understand that um I understand again, I'm the hopium [__]
Like I'm giving you the most idealistic thing. I'm believing
in it and I'm hoping in it. And y'all can just call me >> just
wonder where you would take Trump on his word in other places.
>> Uh believe him on his word about what,
>> You you're you're you're basically coming in here you're
saying, I think Lindsey Graham and Donald Trump are telling the
truth and and this is what's going to happen.
>> Well, no no no, I wasn't saying telling the truth. I
was trying to give you like why I'm reading tea leaves to think
that um Reza Pahlavi is involved in whatever Oh, and then I'll
explain this part, too. Um so, in terms of there being someone
in mind and a day-after plan, I think it is very very intentional
that Trump or the uh >> If they can get to the point where
they could do a day-after plan, we're not even arguing about
that. You have not remotely convinced me that we get to that
place. So, you talk about Pahlavi, you talk about day-after plan.
There's no day-after coming. >> saying I Okay, but listen,
this is >> If if they get to the point where there's day-after
coming, I agree they can install whoever they want. The whole
point is we're arguing before that. What happens before that?
Don't talk to me about Reza Pahlavi if if Reza Pahlavi can walk
into that country without getting shot in the head in 30 seconds,
I agree the US has won and they've overthrown that country and
the Iranian people's lives are going to get better. >> Okay,
so let's take a step back then to where we were a second ago.
Yeah, yeah, sure sure sure. I I just wanted to give you a cuz
that that I guess factors into whatever else we're talking about.
It could help. Uh we're talking about the boots on the ground
and yes, that is exactly the reason um like you generally need
much more um like high-resolution control of things happening
as opposed to just dropping [__] from the sky, right?
To to enforce that level of takeover on the whatever. >> to
hold ground, right? You need to Basically, there there's like
How do you
like distribute force in a way that lets you like maintain law
in some way, right? >> Yeah, exactly. >> there's
nobody that can actually, um, enforce anything that opposes the
RGC right now. Nobody has guns. There's no popular uprising.
You would need plans that have been going on for like what you
said, plans that have been fomenting for like years and years
and years and have stayed totally covert.
>> Okay, this goes brings us back to how and like you can
well, eventually we'll meet the crossroads of where why I think
this guy is relevant and we'll we'll just and if again, even
if we just have to like agree to disagree and then talk about
the hypothetical, we can just do that and then like wrap it up.
I'm not trying to I don't want to get too lost. >> think
it's So, my whole point is that there's no reason to even get
there. Like there's no reason to talk about it unless you can
explain to me how you think they're going to have this country
like this regime fall. Right? The regime has to fall. The regime
is never going to allow lobby into the country. >> I agree.
>> we need to get to where the regime >> Gotcha.
So, the idea is they can bomb both military leaders, um, political
leaders and religious leaders enough and and their like their
their ballistics, um, you know, depots and their their turrets,
like everything that they have basically that is a of of a threat
to the United States. Um, and that's also used as, you know,
>> they have is a threat to the United States or Israel.
Their air defenses have been essentially destroyed since the
12-day
>> If not significantly replenished their air defenses,
their radar stations,
their actual SAM sites. >> so all the things ballistics
the the other army establishments that are whether it's a concern
for Israel, whether those are the tools of oppression for the
people in Iran, those are the things that are being targeted,
and those are the classes of people that are being targeted that
I said prior. Um and so again, I'm in my hypothetical, call it
hopium, but you should have like walk with me down the road so
we can, you know, progress
In my hopium universe, they're able to bomb enough of them, and
there is enough of an organized resistance on the ground that
is covert at the moment, um that there there is a cooperation
happening and communication happening between those two, uh you
know, through whatever back channels that have been being built
for
so so that is the idea is that the the United States is the force
uh equalizer because they have like you said, they don't have
guns, they have nothing, right? The IRGC and the uh military
have a monopoly on force. So, the US is and the again, I'm not
saying, you know, dump Trump's there cuz of the bottom of his
heart. They have their own interests. It just aligns with the
Iranian people
who are whatever, feel oppressed for the last 47 years. >> It
doesn't align with the Iranian people at all. >> Well,
well, that's where we disagree, but that's fine. I'm saying that
like >> cattle, you would understand that the Iranian people
are totally happy with the country and totally totally make that
country fail. >> Yeah, I'm a goytar. That's fine. I'm just
like hear me out and then I can you can call me a and I'll leave.
That's fine. I'm just I'm giving you my uh what the normie Iranian
who's family left the [__] country 40 years ago opinion.
That's that you know, whatever. >> But you have a lot of
family there still, right? Like you talk to a lot of people who
do still live there. >> Yes, yes. And around the world,
but also definitely still there. And then there's friends of
family and there's whatever. It's like yeah, everyone's kind
of whatever, been disjointed, but not everyone made it out or
was like willing to choose to leave back then and then yeah,
just eventually you're kind of too old to make that shift. Um
Well, yeah, anyway, so it's we're living in the we're progressing
in the hopium train where in my, you know, imagination and perspective
uh there is a conversation happening through Pallavi, through
Lindsey Graham, through Donald Trump. Um meaning that, you know,
whatever. That That's the middleman between them uh to connect
these two things and
and Trump is saying that he's going to be there for a while.
He's not saying they're going to leave, right? He's saying like
we're going to be there and we'll, you know, his phrasing was
we're still going to be there to like to help or something like
that, whatever. We'll be there with you um while you guys take
back your destiny. >> Well, they didn't say that. We've
We've given you the opportunity. Now you have to do it. >> Yeah,
but he said but we'll >> It was like It was like he realized
how cold the statement was and he had to like go throw in the
also will help you or >> No No, he's And well, he said
and we'll be there to help you along the way or something like
that. But the point is that's We're both, you know, we're going
to apply our own filters to to what he is or isn't doing in that
moment. I don't think he was kind of like going to correct it.
And so what I was trying to say, and just hear me out for this
sentence, then you can just like don't cut me off from the show.
It's very specifically and strategically intentional that the
United States does not want to be seen as very specifically choosing
this person and endorsing this person. So that's why again when
even Lindsey Graham was asked at whatever UN conference or something
about the Shah of course he >> But the Shah's son?
>> So I'm saying is that >> I'm sorry. Ship on that
sailed, right? >> What are you talking about?
>> I don't I don't even think like the
I don't How could you possibly
Nick is best friends with Lindsey Graham is like the first clue.
>> Okay, and? >> Okay, and nothing. That's not a
clue in any direction. >> Just explain what you mean.
>> Uh you're saying it does You don't want it to be apparent
that the Shah is the has been chosen or propped up by the United
States in some way when that is obvious to everybody with eyes.
>> Sure. I'm saying there that Trump is not Yes, that's
what I'm telling you. I'm saying that Trump is not going to directly
come out and say, "Hey, I want you guys to follow the Shah into
your new government." And that's the guy I'm saying Trump is
not going to state who is doing that work and but when he says
a bunch of people are you know, he's like we got a bunch of people
surrendering saying they want immunity
that's through that organization that Reza Pahlavi has been building
for the last how many years. Pretty sure a couple decades actually
cuz it's been obviously a super long running issue.
And so yeah, I'm telling you is he's not going to explicitly
say it. They're going to be doing it.
this is a coordinated effort in which case Israel gets their
whatever their desires met.
The US has its own objectives and then the Iranian people can
benefit from the opportunity that they haven't had for 47
>> Do you think that concerning it all do you not think
it's concerning it all that anybody who's really on Pahlavi's
side is leaving the country has left the country? Do you not
think there's like a filtering effect >> That that is just
incorrect. You say that I just think that's incorrect. I just
think that is 100% >> What do you think is incorrect?
he doesn't have large
>> Help them leave Iran?
Isn't that what his organization does? They help people get out
of Iran who wanted to affect other countries?
>> No, defect from the government to like be part of the
new non-Islamic regime.
Like so that they have a transition so they don't like just fire
everyone and have to like train 100% new people. Like the whole
issue they had in Iraq where like they just completely [__]
wiped everyone out. >> train 100% people cuz every government
official is literally like a devout Muslim, right? >> The
people that are choosing to surrender to get immunity and be
part of the new whatever it is coalition government type of thing
and transitionary government. So that that was the other question
I need to clarify with you before you're asking that thing of
I'm like worried about
I don't one there is large support for him. If you just look
at protest find me one protest that isn't chanting his name or
saying Javid Shah or putting his face and it's just you just
you can't find those protests that exist >> Protests in
the country who are like are there protesters in the country
who are like going in? >> in in and out but here's one
super important condition. >> and out. I don't the whole
discussion we're having is support on the ground.
yes in the country a lot like here this is this is exactly this
is the ask.
The they can't be wearing hijabs and using the flag that doesn't
have the lion and sun because those are pro-regime
protesters. So and but here's the question here's the thing you
need to do. One, look at the number of protests there are with
both of those different groupings.
People with no hijabs, people with the lion and sun versus people
with hijabs and with the Allahu Akbar flag.
one, you will find like two videos of the pro-regime thing and
the only big one is AI generated.
And then every single other one is
basically pro-Pahlavi. Now, I need to clarify question so we
can be more accurate with where we're going this conversation.
Do you think I'm referring to Pahlavi returning and ruling the
or being a transitionary thing? >> you're referring to
some fantasy land where Pahlavi enters the country and doesn't
get shot in the head in 30 >> Sure sure sure. Actually
contend with what I'm saying. Do you think he's I'm talking about
him returning to be the ruler or to be a transitionary
between the current and the future secular >> figure in
this fantasy land. I I've never really thought about it cuz I
don't really care.
>> Okay, well then you're not really even engaging with
the situation.
>> I'm not engaging with the fantasy. I'm engaging with
the situation on the ground. You've got nearly 200,000 IRGC fighters
in the country of Iran. They know the US has a timetable. They
know the US looks worse and worse the longer they sit there.
They go hide in the mountains, right? They barely send out like
five two maybe one or two percent of their people to maintain
law in any way outside and they just wait the US
You cannot tell me that the US is planning from air aircraft
carriers to individually kill or bomb random IRGC
They all they have to do is have no other opposing force in the
country and wait the US out. Vast majority of their actual military
fighters, of their actual political people will all be
>> I hear your perspective. Obviously, we disagree on how
this will play out, but we'll see. We'll see over time, right?
>> I'm that whole thing Okay, so it's basically Okay, but
I I already concede that if there is some magical thing like
some magical They've they've gotten these people together. They've
gotten like a whole group. Yeah, if that if that exists, if the
if the fantasy that we have no indication for exists, then it's
possible that there is some >> have no you have no indication
of that. I obviously I'm pulling I obviously I'm pulling this
from somewhere, but you have no indication of this cuz we have
different sources of information, media, people that we know.
It is what it is. That's fine. And different, I guess, ways that
we filter and process the information or whatever. It It is what
it is, but >> I It just seems unlikely to me that given
the size of the Iranian regime, given like they have total power
in their country, that if there is a force on the ground that
could oppose them, they have no understanding of that
I I It seems >> Wait, say that last part again. A force
on the ground that could Say the last thing one more time. The
the force on the ground >> that was that was capable of
of that had it organized in numbers to resist them. Like you
don't think that they're smart enough to say, "Well, we're going
to put we're going to Hey, you're in the IRGC, but actually you're
getting kicked out. And what you're going to do is you're going
to go try to join you're going to start slowly like expressing
discontent with the regime. And you're going to go join these
groups, and you're going to get up like >> And then pollute
the inside. >> it's like it's like diplomacy or or spycraft
101, right? Do you think that they're not capable of this? >> No,
of course. That's actually why I think they didn't arm the protesters
because if they if people started getting shot from within the
protest, then you just like people's ability to trust each other,
you could completely the protest from the inside. Um and that's
why I think they just said the US military is going to handle
all the actual force until you guys get your chance to like stampede
the government the way you tried but ran into machine guns last
time. >> How many but K, so they've got machine guns wherever
they are they're going to have machine guns, okay? They're going
to have way more weapons than anybody else. I believe that's
a totally disarmed country, right? Like civilians don't get >> Yeah,
they they have no they have no second amendment or anything like
that. They're totally they're totally just like yeah. Yeah, it's
all based on the fantasy that they can be bombed into submission
which I guess that you think is unlikely.
>> Well, I just How many people have died so far in Iran?
>> Uh, from what at what point?
How many How many people have been killed so far in the strikes?
>> From the strikes in Iran so far. Do we have any casualty
estimates? Any death >> No. Civilians?
I need to go look at the count. It's all very new information.
It was my birth By the way, my birthday was the 28th when the
bombs dropped. Those were birthday bombs, baby. But yeah, so
I've like been with family and [__] I haven't I don't
know the total count. I just keep seeing like oh like 48 guys
killed uh like they're part of the leaders or whatever, right?
That they targeted and then obviously Khamenei was killed and
da da da da uh so I don't I can't even give you a count. But
I but in terms of the Thank you guys. >> I'm going to try
to explain
that you would have to basically keep this stuff up for years
to get rid of the IRGC to grind the IRGC down, right? Now, probably
what's also going to happen is you're probably not going to have
any trade. You're probably going to have like significant
like um just lack of resources. I'm going to guess food's going
to become a problem. >> Water's obviously already a problem.
>> All right. You're going to have like >> Yeah,
you're going to have like probably mass death in this country
as nobody can actually get any trade into the country, right?
Any aid into the country. Let's say 150 to 200,000 IRGC troops
in Iran. >> You have to whittle that number down massively.
Those are people trained and
>> You'd have to whittle that number down massively. The
level of bombing you'd have to do to actually get that number
down significantly, you'd probably have to kill 100,000 people
with only air >> Yeah, I agree with what you're saying.
>> What was I going to say? Sorry. Only air strikes as
well as if if at all possible
to create opportunities like if they bomb a certain site and
civilians are able to like raid those sites and get weapons,
that might end up starting to change the equation on the ground.
But I again, we're just playing in the world of bombs versus
armed and unarmed civilians. That's a >> Yeah, to do this
what you're describing, this would be a multi-year op. Right?
>> No, it'd just be a multi-year operation.
>> I So, my hope or again, it's hard for me to like gauge
it cuz it's just it's like billions and trillions of dollars
is in a way outside of my like conception as a thousandaire,
you know? Um but my hope is that it could be done within weeks.
And I know that's hope you know again, hopeium. Everything I'm
saying is hopeium, so just if you know, put on the same shelf,
right? But um the the ideal or the hope is it would take weeks,
potentially a few months. Um but definitely not years. There
is no desire for boots on the ground or years, which fair enough
if you think that without those two things I won't get the outcome
that we want from it, right? >> would take years.
For them to slowly build up arms in that country such that they
could resist the IRGC and you could bomb the IRGC's like security
force. >> I'm not talk I'm not talking about building up
the arms. That was like a side That that the grabbing arms thing
was like a side thought just in the middle of conversation. And
also it'd be super dangerous to go run for those weapons. I My
whole thought process is about the US bombing them into submission
and adopting enough of them into their like um whatever immunity
slash new government program where they can get a foothold and
uh and then basically seize the government or seize what's like
And they you generally genuinely might just have to actually
kill the 100% of the IRGC members. Realistically, uh all the
ones that don't uh surrender needs to go to prison for life anyways
cuz yeah, like you said, they're going to go into the mountains
and plot their from there. >> I get Do you think Do you
think Donald Trump's telling the truth? Do you imagine Donald
Trump's telling the truth when he says thousands of people have
surrendered already? >> Only because Reza Pahlavi has been
speaking about that through his organization for months, and
I've been whatever listening to him and seeing what the [__]
he's been on about to see if it's valid. Um so, because that's
already a thing, I think he's just referring to that. I don't
think they're calling like Trump. I don't think they're you know,
surrendering to Trump in that way, but I think it in the way
that those two channels have now been connected, I think he's
just referring to that.
To my fantasy coalition of transitionary, whatever, ex-dynasty
guy. Okay. So, I guess like yes is the answer, technically. But,
yeah, in that context, if that makes sense. >> Yeah, I
don't know. I've
I'm sitting here and you basically have like a lot of hope and
>> Yeah, it's totally it's totally fine. >> like
leftist propaganda, but like you the stuff you say like kind
of doesn't make any logistical sense at all.
So, I feel like one of us is propagandized, but it's not me.
>> Well, here's the thing is yours is propagandized, mine
is just home-brewed
I'm pulling this out of my ass. This is opium combined with >> Do
you think I'm pulling like the idea of the estimates of IRGC
troop numbers and my idea of like how much it costs to run a
bombing campaign? Do you think I'm pulling that out of
>> No, no, no, no, no. I know it's just a general focus
on like Israel being the, you know, the only reason this is happening
sort of conversation. But, that's like I don't really don't want
to fight about that. It's I very much hear like the Young Turks
sl- Sorry about that. >> think the reason is? I don't watch
The Young Turks. Unless I can watch Ana do her like her her little
like rubbing her hands motion. I'm literally I only watch highlights
from The Young Turks. I don't watch them. >> Fair enough,
fair enough. It's just like it's your takes are very much lined
up with theirs, Breaking Points and Hasan's, and so it's all
falling into that same sort of category of >> Could you
say what you disagree with? >> I'm not I'm not trying to
use that to discount. I'm saying they all It's like all very
similar
putting things in the context of Israel being the guiding force
and saying there's no reason for America and Iran to have a bad
relationship except for Israel and it's like I mean, that's clearly
not true. You had a bad relationship. What I said, do you disagree
with? >> Oh, I have to remember a specific one of the things.
I mean, really okay, the idea I guess we can go with the largest
claim that the only reason that the States is there is because
Israel wanted them to go.
>> the only substantive reason. Right? Obviously, you could
say I'm sure there are some politicians who would vote against
the War Powers thing getting put in because they actually do
believe in some of the thing like there's probably some on the
margin some other reasons for doing it, but I'm saying the only
substantial reason, the only reason that's different here versus
other conflicts the US could intervene in to me is the idea that
they're defending Israel. >> Okay, I mean, so one thing
is they are for sure doing it to help Israel. That's like I'm
not going to deny that they're
helping one of their allies in the region that is
>> Well, I I'm just going to say that I I agree that that
is absolutely a reason.
The primary reason, well, okay, so keeping it under the self-defense
people say like, you know, Iran Iran is so far away, they can't
reach us that it doesn't matter. That's a matter of time. That's
a matter of when not if, right? They will eventually have intercontinental
whether that's 2 weeks or 2 years or like 20 years, it doesn't
matter. This is not something that's going to solve itself without
complete dominance and regime change. That is you're not changing
religious fanatic freaks that hate your country. So, it's a question
of when not if. So, that's the like in the short term it's Israel's
concern, in the long term I mean, whatever in the American bases
and allies in the region blah blah blah, but in terms of the
continent of North America, that's a long-term concern. And then
in terms of what economic benefits there are for the United States
I think is also a huge factor. Um opening up to open up trade
and having another
>> Yes, to be able to open up trade with another country
like that and basically help juice the economy in that way, but
more specifically and you asked me for the source, I'll have
to go back. But you're just saying words. What are they What
are they trading to Iran and getting from Iran?
I'm not going to go down the rabbit hole of specifics on individual
things that are being traded when trade becomes open. I'm giving
you that as an umbrella. I'll give you the one specific thing
I mentioned in chat with you guys for reference. I'll have to
get you later. But when it comes to the oil, I think this is
a larger long-term plan that's been in place for like at least
a year since they started sanctions on on on Iran and probably
when they started planning with Venezuela. I think this is part
of a much larger
scope plan where one, they want to uh seize the oil production
from Venezuela and Iran because they were selling them like black
market under the table cheaper oil and avoiding like circumventing
the US dollar to give it to China for cheap. And so they want
them to buy it through them at whatever higher prices and then
China has to decide to eat the economic hit um instead of going
to war cuz it's probably not worth the little bit of a tax on
your oil. And also because the oil in Venezuela is heavy crude
and Iran has heavy crude as well as like light and medium light.
So they can use that to dilute the heavy crude which is basically
necessary for effectively
um pumping that oil, right? And using it. So it's like a larger
chess move is being made to control the board as well as to enhance
whatever like those whatever five five big oil companies um And
yeah, all the stuff they've been doing currently with Venezuela.
So that's that's what I think is in it for the United States
is that larger scope thing with controlling
>> I this stuff to China >> But like the array of
like multiple partners right there is Iran really substantially
changing this uh from from them obtaining light crude from the
Middle East. >> Bro, it's >> They've got every every
other major country there is aligned with the United States.
Like every other major oil producing country is aligned with
the United States. >> That's not a reason. That's not a
>> to the equation going to significantly Well, you just
said the idea that you would get the light crude from Iran.
And just because they have light crude
>> getting It's just all of it. Just just all of it. Literally
all of it. All of it is massive money and the Iranian people
are super willing to give a large
of that to America
um moving forward. Again, this is one of those like Where am
I getting it? I'm getting it from people, but we'll see as time
tells, right? Um just categorize everything I'm saying as hopium
or whatever. You just fantasy and then we'll just see over time,
right? That'll be the fun part. But um but yeah, so there is
oil interest in it for America on a much larger scale than just
like what they can buy from someone else to um use to dilute.
They're like, "No, we can extract it ourselves and profit from
selling it." Not just, you know what I'm saying? Pay someone
else to get this other stuff to be more uh viable or feasible.
Yeah, it's just like a way better opportunity for them. And again,
there's um it's all the terrorist proxies that are being funded
from like there's there's other
downstream effects, right? Like second third order effects that
um do just in in general benefit Western nations. But um yeah,
again, we can just agree
it's general security not having Hezbollah, Hamas, the Houthis.
Like these guys taking tankers and boats, like pirates. If you
defund those guys >> of Western nations. I The Houthis
maybe you could argue, but
>> Well, again, you you uh
for you it's like a every every way to just pin it all on Israel,
but like October 7th obviously was one of those attacks, right?
>> Well, it's not pinning it on Israel. There's there's
there's a significant threat to Israel and basically nobody
And also, they definitely still are a threat to other people
in the region. I guess you just don't mean like
Yeah, like Europe still
And what What is Okay, so yeah, one How long do you think until
they are a threat? Do you just think you'll never have a threat,
or you're kicking the can down the road? >> No, but you
you uh you clip the grass when they're being threats, right?
When they're actually in some way a real >> So every time
you see them rebuilding, you just go bomb it? Like you just go
>> I said I said I said I said I said I said I said I said
I said I said I said I said I said I said I said I said I said
I said I said >> Okay, yeah. And you would just want them
to repeat that like on a yearly basis, or whenever they see that
oh [__] they're rebuilding it. All right, let's go.
Let's stabilize that. >> way to do it for the United States.
>> Okay. I understand that's that's your perspective on
it. And so, yeah, I think that the choice he's making is we can
shift the whole region so we don't have to do like a bombing
campaign that lasts for infinite time, and we always have to
worry about them just being more and more mad at us as we keep
bombing their [__] I think he's actually >> a
bombing campaign of to a bombing campaign for infinite time is
a bombing campaign for infinite time. Where there's no boots
on the ground. Honestly, like you should be >> wait, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry. I I I said yeah before you said infinite
Just to be super clear. >> be putting boots on the ground.
>> It's for a short period of time was what I meant to
say yes to. Sorry. What about boots on the ground?
>> If they actually had significant concern for the Iranian
people or their interests, they would be putting boots on the
ground. >> Why Why you What is this like a moral frogging
about the interests of the Iranian people?
What is this? What are you doing? >> I'm trying to explain
to you that if they didn't want to just destabilize the country,
right? >> Oh, okay. Okay. >> If they wanted true
stability, they'd be putting boots on the ground. >> This
is assuming I'm wrong about the having enough boots on the ground
because 80% or 89% of the population wants a democratic system.
Um again, 50% of the sorry, country support Pallavi as a transitionary,
30% support him as a
but so, assuming that that's all incorrect and that all those
people could not cuz you were saying before, if that exists,
if this like back channel
whatever, a committee and the the channels for people to defect
and if all this stuff is in place and you have a massive uprising
of people who have been in the streets for months and have tried
multiple times every couple years and it's the same [__]
every day. The only thing that's different this time is that
Trump came to bomb the IRGC and it gives them a chance. That's
literally the only thing that's different this time. Well, and
actually people were more pissed this time and people are more
pissed because of the 30 plus thousand, 32 plus thousand deaths.
Um, that hit harder. I think that was the largest number of protest
deaths over the other ones since the big purge in '79, which
was like 30,000 leftists got merked immediately and then other
groups as well.
I'm going to pull these up. Can you tell me which of these are
AI, which one of these was the AI version?
>> Um, these are like videos here.
>> Wait, wait, no, no, no. Hold on, hold on, hold on. We're
talking about before Khamenei got blown up. Obviously, now that
you killed the supreme leader, a bunch of people are going to
I'm not saying the I'm saying because you were talking about
the support for Reza Pahlavi. That was the whole point of me
talking about the number of protests that are anti-regime versus
pro-regime and the general support for Reza Pahlavi. I'm not
saying as of February 28th, now that the supreme leader has been
killed, that Muslims aren't mad. Obviously, they're mad and they're
going to retaliate. That's What are we talking about? >> I
mean since you're taking away their not putting boots on the
ground. So, my argument is the Islamic Republic, the the Islamic
regime that's there,
the Muslim regime will lose power.
>> Obviously, the army is also retaliating,
you're saying they're not going to lose power because what? Because
there's no boots on the ground.
>> Because there's no there's no like tangible support
against this. And yeah, you just killed the leader of the
>> Yeah, but I thought we established though Are we working
on the premise of my version where there is enough of a coalition
of like an uprising of whatever 80% of the population that does
want to >> No, we're not operating on the fantasy premise.
I'm asking you about You basically say 89% of the population
>> I'm saying fantasy premise because you think it's that.
I'm telling you that's what's going to Yes. Yes, that is the
silent majority. Well, or at this point loud majority actually.
What do you What do you What are you What are you pointing at
right now about this? Like yes, there are people with the Islamic
flag. >> Pointing at these protests that are
>> Yes, as of 2018
>> Okay, so again, you are doing a very intentional context
thing. The conversation we're having is about the last 2 months
wondering what support there is for Reza Pahlavi. What percentage?
And I said, "So if you show me protests that are before the 28th
that have that flag [clears throat]
>> and I'll and that aren't just in the room with the supreme
leader with like a couple hundred >> You rally behind the
flag effect is >> Uh where you you got to Just you know,
again, explain it to me. Let me not Let me not do the guessing
game >> No, you you had it. Yeah, when you get attacked,
you rally around the literal >> Yes, yes, yes. I Okay,
I totally >> part of my point the entire time. Do you think
the Muslims in this country, who are a significant portion are
Persian, do you think they like America? Do you think they're
going to accept an American puppet as their leader? >> It's
not >> think there's any question that Reza Pahlavi's father
was an American puppet?
>> No, of course not. He was literally, you know, paid
by for the coup in '53 and he was obviously like super pro-Western
and trying to like >> we ever believe that these people
would want Reza Pahlavi?
Like this crowd would never vote for him or never accept Reza
Pahlavi even in an intermediary even in an intermediary period,
right? >> Just go Do me Do me a favor. You're You understand
what you're saying right now. The supporters of Khomeini, his
the people who still wear bedsheets on their head in 2026, that
those people don't support the guy that opposes the bedsheet
guy. Obviously, yes, the acolytes of Khomeini or Khamenei um
are not Pahlavi sup- supports. No one's saying that. But also,
you say that these are the people >> 87% of the country.
Where
I just see a lot of people rallying behind this flag. >> And
you what you what you keep doing is also pulling it from the
28th where the bombs are falling, people know to stay inside.
They've been instructed to say ins- stay inside. You need to
just quickly go to YouTube and look up like a supercut of protests
for the last two full months.
If you ignore the last two full months and you just want to point
to these guys >> they wanted that they wanted regime change?
That they wanted like the the leader dead? That they wanted to
rebel against the leader? They were upset with the leader? Do
you think I dispute that? Over the past 2 months. >> That's
not the question at hand. The question is the support for Pahlavi.
>> Okay. You got to show me something for something for
Pahlavi.
But like
I just I The everybody I've seen who has any amount of like understanding
of the region. I've not seen a single serious actor. I don't
even think I've seen somebody go on like US television who claims
to be like an expert on the region who will say that Reza Pahlavi
has significant support.
>> So, you just haven't really been watching it or don't
know who experts are on the region. I don't know what to tell
you. Like it's just it's goofy. It's comical.
>> Uh wait. Can you link me like an interview with somebody
who's like, "Yeah, there's real support for Reza Pahlavi on the
ground. We think that Reza Pahlavi is going to be welcomed back
to lead this country into the
To lead this country into a democratic
>> Yes, I can. The issue >> want somebody who's willing
who has a strong reputation who's willing to stake that reputation
saying, "I believe Reza Pahlavi will enter this country, be welcomed
by the people, and lead it into a bright new future."
Like these protests look I don't see protests like this in America.
Like these protests look massive. >> Did you Hold on. Did
you see the um Did you see the Iranian protest the day of action
in Toronto? Google >> Why would I care about you? Why would
I care about the Iranian protest day of action in Toronto? >> What's
the thing you said before this? You haven't seen crowds this
size in
>> In America, yeah.
>> Yes. So, when I say the
Day of action. Day of action. Day of action Toronto
video. It's global day of action. Okay, what is this? This is
for Iran? Global day of action.
You need to go like this.
>> Yeah, there's absolutely
There's a Yeah. >> Day of action Toronto. >> up the
Look up new stories that say 350,000
people
>> It's got to be better than that. It's got to be better
than that. >> No, no, no, no. This is that stupid drone
actually should be flying. There's
And I mean like it's flying down the street, not on parking lots.
It's just like This is not Hold on, let me Okay, that's at least
better, but that not Let me Let me try and find video that's
actually going to be good. >> I just want to see if we
got to the front of it here. I think we are basically at the
back of it and it's going forward like this. So, were you talking
about this march or were you talking about something else? >> Whatever
that is is not That is barely
All right, hold on. I'll let you >> are shoulder to shoulder.
>> I know. I know. Don't worry. You'll see. You'll see
and I'm I promise you it's actually that much and more. I just
need to get like actual footage cuz
>> Are you looking at what's on What's What's on the screen
right now?
Yes, I do. >> This is in This is in Tehran, so this would
probably be the biggest protest. Okay. I think they were really
with their government. I think they were perfectly willing to
protest significantly against their government, right?
>> Like I I totally agree with that, that they were very
upset with their government, that they probably were even calling
for the death of Khamenei or or the regime in general. I would
believe that, too. But, I think once you once rubber meets the
road and the US comes in and assassinates the Ayatollah, the
supreme leader of your country, the leader of your religion,
I think things change very quickly. >> Right, that's what
I'm telling you. So So that's what I'm telling you. The people
with the Pahlavi flag have literally, and I mean verbatim, for
the last 2 months saying, "Trump, please come help us. Come bomb
us." And that's why people are celebrating. The people who are
going to rally behind the flag are the ones rallying behind this
Islamic flag. And that is the 10%
Yeah, this is Again, this is like a better Definitely better
one. It's not as complete. I want the one with the drone and
the flag all the way down.
>> No, no, no. Like this is This is really good. This is
way more. >> Yeah. This is what I Yeah, look Look how far
that goes. It's starting to get up 350,000
is the whatever estimate on it, but yeah, 350,000. Objectively
the largest protest ever in Toronto, which again, whatever, you
can say, "Oh, it's Toronto. It's not that or that downtown."
But like
There There can't be this much of a disconnect between the diaspora
or whatever and the people in that are like non-regime supporters
in the country,
Um and the the idea that it's like 10% or 20%. >> Why are
they diaspora?
Why are they >> Because they were literally killing people
and purging people after the revolution. They got lied to. >> They
ended up Because they weren't willing to look the other way in
any way for the things the the Iranian regime was trying to do
to gain control and maintain control.
Because they fundamentally, foundationally disagree with the
way they were running the country.
When a lot of those people leave, what do you think happens to
the country? >> Wait, hold on. Walk me through. What are
you What are you saying right now?
You're saying I'm saying that after the after the after the revolution
>> People with massive
like no way they could possibly agree with this regime. They
find ways to make new lives in new places. Now, while there will
be disagreements with the current regime, all of these strongest
dissenters, when they see that dissent is going to get them killed,
they leave. That causes the country to shift in a direction,
right? Obviously.
>> Uh not quite, but I get I get your point. I get your
point. >> I mean, it obviously does. So, what I'm telling
you is this is why there would be a massive disconnect between
diaspora
and the people in the country. >> Right. I'm telling you
though, it actually isn't that massive. I would agree the percentage
is different because I don't think people that are in the country
that agree with how the country is run would ever leave to live
anywhere else. Cuz why the [__] would they, right?
They're in their like their own version of life that they want
there, right? So, obviously like if there's in my opinion like
10 to 15% of the population is extreme Muslim. Um, cuz even Persians
are like, "We're not really Muslim people. They got like put
onto us." So, in my opinion, it's like 10 to 15% of people in
the country >> the Persian population is sincere Shia?
You think it's they just identify Shia because they were told
you have to be Shia to be here? >> Yes, and you will be
killed if you A lot of people have to just identify
so they don't get
Cuz they literally will just It's It's going against God. And
that's the thing. You can't go against God. You're an infidel.
You will be [__]
>> literally killed. Um, so yeah, it's like you're you're
being forced into it. It's not a choice. Um, so the idea is that
it's And again, this is from the uh, you know, ear on the pavement
of people that were connected to that land. I understand that
when people leave, I get totally what you're saying. It changes
the culture and whatever. But the people there have regretted
it like literally
weeks or days afterwards. They were like, "Oh my God, we've Bring
the Shah back." Like they they knew immediately they got lied
to. They got scammed by this sweet talker who turned out to just
be a crazy dictator. And then they started purging and killing
people in the thousands.
And they basically were like crushing dissent and they had massive
brain drain cuz all the people that are educated were like, "I'm
getting the [__] out so my life isn't completely
wrecked." Which is like if you look at the the currency currently,
what a joke, right? Like thank God my family got out of there
or I'd be in that [__] mess and my my dollar would
be worth zero, right? So, those like not everyone had the luxury
of getting out. But, that doesn't mean that the people that are
still there are happy to be there or they're happy under this
regime. They've been unhappy for years and they've they've been
trying to get out of it, but they have no way out. Like, there
is And that maybe brings me to my question to you if if you're
down. What is the alternative? Like, what is the solution if
you are under the boots of a dictator
if not
uh external military force?
Again, assuming you don't have any physical force, right? What
is I guess your thing would be I think it'd be all that, but
also with specifically boots on the ground, right? That's just
like the only Is that No, but sorry, let me leave it open to
you. What are your alternate Also, sorry, my Are you quiet right
now or is my headphones on? >> I'm listening. I'm also
looking for something. But, um >> Cool, cool. >> So,
you're asking me what's my alternative to what? Boots on the
ground from the country? >> Well, sorry, sorry. Just like,
what is the the Iranians feel trapped under a regime for last
47 years and they use like brutal methods to keep them
Outside of something like Trump and Israel showing up and um
basically bombing them to create an opportunity for you know,
the takeover, what is um And again, if the answer might just
be that plus boots on the ground, but if not military intervention,
what is the other solution? Cuz obviously, you can't just like
ask them nicely, right? You can't negotiate with
>> what is the way out of the the oppression?
>> It might be fleeing the country.
No, I mean, to stop the oppression in the country.
>> To stop the oppression in the country.
>> What other solution is there than uh military force
from external forces cuz you don't have it and to push a regime
>> I mean, I think you're kind of just
>> Yeah, yeah. Like
So, I I understand what you're saying that for the Iranian people
who who do feel like there's no other tenable way out of the
situation, like what else could they do but ask for like the
the bombing that's happening. I mean I they would have to ask
for boots on the ground. That's like the real thing is if you
want if you want substantial regime change, you would need boots
on the >> That's fair. So so it's a it's like a more detailed
and and complete version of the military external force. Okay,
that's fair. I can give you that because we already went over
the whole
tactical necessity of that whole situation and >> Cuz the
the other situation would be like you would need to coordinate.
Let's say you could have these people on the ground. They would
not be trained fighters, right? Let's say you have a massive
Let's say there's a 100,000 person militia that's really that's
willing to go. Somehow
the US and and Israel have smuggled weapons into this country
the whole time and they can arm this 100,000 person militia.
Okay, now they're actually against a militia that has fought
wars there a military that has fought wars. Right?
Are they going to but they've got air support from the Americans?
It's like That's I don't think that's possible, right? I'm pretty
sure that's not possible at all. And so I don't know
Yeah, without it being infiltrated and them all being killed.
I don't know how like there's just no I don't see how
>> Well, just infiltrating these groups would be top priority
for the regime. It's almost certainly It's almost certainly something
they're good at because they have not been top toppled like ever.
So yeah, I just don't know. I I'm sitting here and I'm like
>> No, I look, I want to make it clear. I fully agree with
you that this is like the most Herculean task. It is complete
It's like the 0. It's the what's the you know, in a million 600,000
It's like It's like the one outcome.
It's like the >> It's not a reasonable outcome and I think
there's a lot of reasons to shape opinion in this way from other
people so that you believe it so that when they go, well, we
tried our best guys and now Iran's in total chaos and it's like
everybody they has far worse lives now. Like they're going to
go, "Well, we tried." But they didn't try. >> that's Israel's
intention, right? Or I guess also Trump's, but >> Syria
2.0. Yes, Syria 2.0. Or like at best, they're hoping like really
what they're what they're probably their ideal situation is you
just get somebody who is a corrupt sweet talker who could say
like, "Okay, we're going to give you whatever you want." And
just like stop bombing us and we'll we'll stop doing that and
everything will be fine, right? But it'll still be the IRGC.
Like that's probably what they're hoping for, right? Is somebody
that will come along and just say, "Okay, stop." By the way,
if if somebody comes along and they are
and they say, "Okay, um we actually we we want the bombing to
stop, we won't pursue a nuclear program, we will not even pursue
our drone program or our missile program. We'll sit here, we'll
be like basically defenseless. Just stop the bombing, we we surrender,
but like we're going to stay in power." Do you think the US will
accept or decline that offer? >> I think they decline that
offer. I don't think they trust Iran to not just then rebuild
with the same uh fanatics in
>> Cuz that's that's the pattern, right? That's And that's
basically what Trump said. He's like, "Can't trust Iran." >> American
people, right? >> About what?
>> So the reason they're saying they're doing this is that
the the Ayatollah gave them the wrong answers on nukes and their
missile program.
>> That's That was the reason he did this. They were trying
to negotiate. I assume they were negotiating in good faith in
some way. And they said, "So if they basically the new leader
comes in and they accept all demands." And they say so publicly,
"We accept all demands of the United States. We are going to
live peacefully. We're just going to continue on with our thing
here." You don't think they stop shooting? >> No, I don't.
And I don't think that the um negotiations in the first place
were in good faith. I think they had already been planning to
go in there. Like I said, they have their own uh oil intense,
they have their own national security thing. Israel has its own
other like more local national security issues or uh concerns.
Uh I think I think this has been a plan in place for like at
least a year.
that the negotiations were intentionally something Iran could
not accept so that they could get to a point where they're like,
well, guess we got to go in there and we're going to free the
Iranian people, which again, it's just three people that are
completely Well, I'm not completely separate. Iran or sorry,
Israel and the United States are obviously in cahoots, but they're
two separate interests align and is a fortunate like whatever
stroke of luck for the Iranian people's interests to give them
a chance to, you know, hopefully create a better version of life
cuz they were trapped otherwise. And there was truly, like you're
saying, without boots on the ground or a military intervention,
there is truly no way out, right, from a like a super theoretic
dictatorship with all the guns, right? There is no option. So
>> Yeah, no, a well-a well-managed regime, like I think
we've seen this pretty conclusively in China. If you're willing
to kill any dissenters, if you're a really well-managed, like
well-oiled machine, you're never going to be displaced in the
modern world. Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. But >> So basically,
yeah, I think that, um, one, Iran is not trustworthy and I think
Trump just knows that. So, um, I guess like there's maybe a world
where if they really gave all the actual correct concessions
or like did it sooner without too much pushback or something
like that, maybe and like an extreme amount of oversight on their
own clock, like anytime the US wants they could show up to inspect,
but Sorry, what's up? You're going to say >> So, well,
there's there's there is the chance that something happens outside
of what you would expect, right? Outside of like what I've seen,
where they do have this like force with weapons that does come
and like take something over. The miracle situation, I can't
discount that that's like it's within the realm of the possible.
Is it probable?
>> I'm I'm saying it's like super It's like the super rare
legendary rare drop. It's It's a It's not likely. It's just the
>> I just wouldn't bet the future of your country on the
super ultra rare drop, >> Here's the thing. The This is
And this is the like This is how [__] it is. I was
talking to my parents about it
You know it's literally that bad
this is the only option and there is like they felt like there
is no future. Like the country is completely the economy is completely
the sanctions were not going to get lifted and lifting the sanctions
would only keep the regime in place which they already hated
regardless of the sanctions. They hated them since 79 and just
regretted the decision for 47 full years. So it is very much
like anything will be better than this and even if it could get
worse the chance for that thing that's better is absolutely
worth taking versus just staying under the boot of like the mullahs.
That's the calculation that they had to make that it's like this
is the only chance
but like we have nothing protecting here. >> there's there's
there's like no chance. >> Sure. I mean that's the disagreement
of perspectives and again they're they're working for a miracle
shift right now. I understand that. I I understand that I'm and
also I understand that you're using pattern recognition from
prior events and like whatever other wars. I'm just thinking
that it's different in Iran than Iraq and I do think that there
is actually hope this time. Well which >> Do you think
What do you think was different about Iraq versus the way Iran
is managed? What do you think was different?
well on one level I'm just talking about the cultures like the
Iraqi people versus the Iranian people I think are fundamentally
different people with fundamentally different pasts and the people
who are alive right now were still alive in the country before
this revolution. So it's not like these people didn't know what
life was like before. The younger generation obviously has only
seen it in videos or heard stories from their family but um there
is something to go back to there that was actually civilized
that was actually westernized and like they want to recapture
that as well as very intentionally and specifically emulating
North America. I mean yeah I don't give a [__] People
are very very I guess you're Iranian. I guess >> I guess
that's like I that's like um >> default born with racism.
It's in my [laughter] code. >> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Come on,
I got you. I mean, no, no, but peace and love to all the people,
but um But yeah, and also the way that that
was carried out and the level of destruction, like like we were
saying before, they do need to try and adopt as many people over
from
the current whatever version of administration and all that.
And like like look, you get immunity or you're getting killed.
Like that that offer does need to take effect
it's a some large enough percentage where the transition can
be more stable than what happened in Iraq. And
you know, again, fingers crossed, but creating a a referendum
environment for an election. >> You understand
with the public information, there's a very there's probably
a hundred to a thousand times larger chance
that you end up in an Iraq or Syria 2.0 situation, where you
have like
just the baddest, the worst people who can grab power through
violence, who can obtain some weapons and grab power through
violence, all fighting and warring in the same place, and totally
there's just no country that can exist within that framework,
right? >> Yeah. Like just factions and all >> Yes.
So, you understand there's probably a hundred to a thousand times
larger chance of that happening than anything else? Oh, sorry,
then Basically, the the hierarchy of chance here is there's way
higher chance of that happening, and then there's a way higher
chance of the IRGC just maintaining control.
You still think Let's say Let's say this happens, where where
it's just like Iraq 2.0. There's just nothing like civilization
basically disintegrates. You think this was all still worth it?
You're you're perfectly happy.
All of these people are just like long term. >> Uh perfectly
happy would obviously not properly characterize how I would feel
about it. It would be >> You You think you've You think
you've made a bet that's justifiable.
Every single Iranian I've spoken to or have any sort of even
like multiple degrees of connection to, I have not heard a single
Iranian person not at one single one that is like no guys this
is not the way forward we shouldn't do it this way. Everyone
is like oh you guys are anti-war about Iran now? How about shut
the [__] up and never speak again ever again and
then whatever other TOS [__] I don't want to say.
Every everyone is like that so >> So I would wonder why
does this not change your mind at all? The like after Khomeini
is killed why does that is the mass support in the streets? Why
does that not change your mind at all? >> On change my
mind on what though?
>> On whether or not there will be support for a like a
uprising of some kind. >> Because because you are specifically
getting footage of the pro regime like the pro Islamist crowd
and you're actively I don't want to ignore I'm not trying to
be like a toxic or whatever but like there are 100 other examples
of the pro Pallavi anti-regime people celebrating in this way.
They can't gather like this in Iran because they're being bombed
and literally Trump said they're going to be going off everywhere
stay inside like get ready for the moment for you to like take
over institutions and Pallavi also said if the internet gets
cut down if the if the all the communication if the satellite
next to the I have radio as well like they have
boots on the ground levels of communication for if those blackouts
and things take place. So these people this doesn't change anything
because it's just saying like oh the pro Khomeini people are
still pro Khomeini people. I didn't expect them to change their
mind. I'm just saying they're the minority in in my perspective
and that when it's safe enough to go outside or if you look at
again diaspora you could say it's just like a biased of people
that would be against it right? But so those people have the
ability to be celebrating the they're like the parties were crazy
the gatherings were crazy last night and but the people in the
country have to like they're dealing with the actual threat right?
Like they're in the thick of it. They're the ones on with their
lives on the line for the potential outcome of like the the whole
country's future. So they can't be out there they it's crazy
if this footage is from
If it's And not because they're getting together, because they're
for being outside. Like they're just asking to get literally
like oh, we can just delete all the people that are crazy. Like
that's That's a perfect place for the uh for what's it called?
For Trump to drop a quick B2, you know what I'm saying? You know,
eliminate all that all those people that >> I know what
you're saying. You're like saying something completely insane,
but >> Oh, hell yeah. Oh, yeah. I mean, you know, the the
the circumstances is kind of crazy, too, right?
So, anyways, point is these people don't represent the majority.
And yes, if you point if you There is no point being made by
just saying, "Look, Khamenei supporters are Khamenei supporters."
Like this doesn't change anything. >> I see evidence of
Khamenei support.
>> Yeah, from the people that were already his supporters.
Not the majority.
>> Yep. But these are the people like these These aren't
even the people with the weapons. I don't I don't think these
are necessarily armed. >> But basically between the army
and this mass of people that are out here, I'm not seeing um
any indication that there's a mass of people who could who could
get together, muster, and bear bring some force to bear that
allows them to turn the tables in this country. >> Right.
So, I'm just telling you and like as far as I'm aware, it is
fact that the people that would be opposed to this group is multiple
times larger. It's just again, I I'm not going to pull foot That
footage will not exist today because there is there is no chance
they're going to go out and protest right now or like gather
to dance in the streets >> I do I do understand that >> Can
you You know, at least agree with that, right? That's like >> can
Yeah, I can actually agree that like this would be the absolute
worst time to go out and do any sort of anti-regime protest cuz
they are obviously going to just say you're somebody we could
go against you're somebody you're somebody we could cut down
for free and
>> Yeah, and it's Yeah, also you're identifying yourself
to the you know, to them as they retaliate as well as you just
like putting yourself in harm's way as you're basically hiding
in the basement, right? It's just like crazy to even be outside
in Iran right now. Um so that's why I'm also kind of like it's
it's it's hard to be judging this and trying to compare anything
from February 28th. Again, I'm not saying that these things don't
exist. And my claim about the um very few videos and if not the
only large one being AI generated was prior to 28th, right? They're
talking about over the last 2 months, not this like allegedly
AI generated >> Nobody's going to go out and like do a
do a like cheer for the regime when they're under sanctions and
everybody's like way of life is just getting decimated, right?
>> The pro-regime people? Yes, they are. They absolutely
would. And that's why a bunch of them were inside the uh inside
the whatever hall with the supreme leader as he was giving a
speech. Um yeah, bowing and listening to their mans. They don't
care that they're not worried about like trying to
convince America to lift sanctions by the civilians not they're
just hey, you guys are anti-regime or pro-regime. That's that's
as far as they're thinking the like the peoples, right? The actual
>> The foreign minister is going to try and sweet-talk
America. Be like, "No, we're very nice people. We have very peaceful
nuclear program." But uh but the actual like whatever um Islamic
supporters or regime
I don't think they're thinking about the optics and then not
protesting. I think they just don't have that much of a massive
support and there was like tens and tens of thousands. And it
was in like all cities across the whole country, right? >> Um
I didn't see all of it. It seemed like it was in the major places.
I saw one that looked very big.
>> There should be um whatever news stories that came out
at the time that were like whatever like 20 cities or whatever.
I don't know what the numbers were. >> but I guess if if
I I do accept that around 30 plus thousand people were killed.
So 30,000 protesters were killed over like a a weeks, then I
would have to imagine the protests were very were multiple times
larger than that. >> For sure. And that's obvious I would
assume that was also across the whole country, not just in Tehran.
Um, so it's like yeah. >> Yeah, sure, sure, sure. >> reach
those numbers in that short of time. And because again, yeah,
the IRGC is everywhere. They've got a massive
I'm not sure that that's signaling like
I'm not sure that's signaling long-term dissatisfaction such
that you would want the US to come. That you would say USA and
Israel save
I don't see So, I see that as dissatisfaction with the regime
who's letting their lives get destroyed, who's letting their
lives get worse. I don't see that as like, oh, now we're big
fans of Israel and the United States.
>> I just don't see it. >> Excuse me. Do you Are
you saying that you don't Like cuz I can literally find you This
should be easy to find. Um, just like Iranian protesters calling
for Trump. And like they're literally just like please >> I I
saw one person go like I love Trump when uh bombs went off, but
it was a school kid or something. >> Oh, no, that's after
the fact. I'm talking about cuz that 28th was like all of our
prayers have been answered. And I said the last 2 months actively
and my dad's like, you mean 47 years? I was like, yeah, yeah,
but like since these protests at New Year's, it's been every
day people are like, you said you're coming, you said you're
coming, what the [__] You're leaving and more people
are dying every day. And uh Trump kept going, oh, you know, I
stopped the hangings. And we're like, yeah, but they're still
getting executed in the back, what the [__] And then
it was just a matter of They needed to wait for him to do things
militarily strategically, but they've been begging for it. Like
literally. This should be easy to find. If you want me to pull
up like some video or this actually might also lead to the Like
you're talking about prominent Iranian like activists or speakers
or people that were like on the news talking about supporting
Pahlavi. That That would also probably like be attached to this
type of please come, Trump. Please help us. >> Yeah. I
don't know why
So, I just don't see why there would be significant material
support behind
the former symbol of oppression because of the current symbol
of oppression.
>> Uh because the calling him the former symbol of oppression
is a uh is basically just kind of misinformation. Um and I understand
whatever the story is and that he was a terrible person, blah
blah blah. A lot of that was literally like an MI6 and CIA psyop
to get that protest in the first place and whatever. It was like
yeah, both things SAVAK, they were trained by uh the CIA and
MI6. It's like, "Yo, these are using American
tactics and shit." They were They just Yeah, whatever. Sorry,
I don't mean to uh fight with my wand in chat. I got no no hate
for him, but uh I got distracted there. Anyway, so the idea that
he was the oppressor was a mistake. >> with her. >> No,
no, no. I genuinely I mean, we can talk at some point, but I'm
I'm not trying to get bogged down on that one point right now.
I genuinely I like talking about these progressive >> is
basically like the secret police for the Shah and they did >> Yeah,
yeah. It's It's their protest or >> That's what I'm saying.
That's the story. I've heard it. I get it. Again, also things
in the context of that
Uh I It's a question of whether I believe um like what extent
of it and what extent is like uh any quote unquote worse or more
extreme than what is done in like North America or in England
or any of these other countries. So, uh that again, that's a
whole other conversation to dive into. >> at it
>> America is not without sin. America does some crazy
[__] CIA black sites. >> I said something prior
to that that's different, which is you need to take this into
the con- context of the Middle East where like the change the
the radical change between '53 and '79 is like an insane amount
of like civil
civil evolution basically, right? So, I'm not I'm not supporting
or saying it's good that they were doing that type of [__]
I think they live in the kind of context at that time and I'm
not going to sit here and cry about that one feature of it in
connection or in contrast to the many, many, many other positive
things where they refer to that the Pahlavi age as the golden
age. So, when you say you you think they don't want to crush
one oppressive figure to return to another oppressive figure
within days there were people out in the streets crying saying
bring back the Shah it within days and that never really stopped.
So people realized that he actually was the goat. Hey, the white
revolution was actually dope giving women the right to vote making
the legal age to [__] [__] 18 like letting
them work in Parliament letting them fly fly [__]
fighter jets and [__] like he he made everyone literate
made reading free. He was bro
pumped the prosperity of that nation in like unimaginable ways
and you can look this [__] up it's all like factual
numbers that you can look up and uh and trust me after 47 years
with Khomeini there is um people do not see the Shah as
the last oppressor they see him as the goat and the one that
they let down as a
That is how people see >> the original Shah. >> So
I've been watching some of Joanna's coverage the past couple
days. I want to play this stuff from Joanna right here and she's
going to give her like thoughts on this. >> Do I think
that the son of the Shah should be put in after American intervention?
No, I don't think that will work. I don't think that works. So
in terms of do I think their regime there should be regime change?
I do not believe that that is the question of the moment. Um
because I don't think that's really up to external powers.
I think that
>> All right, go on. Go on. >> should happen is there
should be a deal that promotes peace in the region and economic
integration of Iran because economic integration would create
the biggest difference for the people of Iran and if the people
of Iran weren't starving then perhaps they'd be able to make
stronger political movements.
Maybe if the people of Iran weren't crippled by sanctions. Um
for whatever you want to say the government is incredibly strong
and incredibly willing to use
uh power against its people. And as I said before, there are
20 to 30 million
who are willing to defend that regime. It's a country of 93
million people. So, for all that you've heard who are oppressed
by the regime, do not discount
how many are willing to defend it. So, I am interested in what
can actually help the people and what is actually worth doing.
Regime change to me, it's it's a weird, hawkish principle that
is the same as gifting democracy. What I'm interested in is what
is best for the people and economic integration
where
uh America's integrated Well, you can What is the argument that
economic integration failed with China? Do we not believe that
China's movements are stymied somewhat by their economic integration?
I mean, that's the argument Trump would make that the deal was
>> I think this is generally like the argument of um most
liberals is that you basically show how much better it is under
the liberal world order, under the the Western world order. Like,
you can just integrate your economy and that's best for everybody.
>> Right? Okay. Um so, I I'm I genuinely I'm going to try
to just keep things respectful cuz I I don't know this person.
I don't mean to talk [__] Uh I do think what she
said a bit comical, a bit naive. Um tell me, over the last 47
years, have they not had the Western example to be followed?
And was it not that the country was being hyper-Westernized
leading up to '79? And then anti-Western people took it over.
They asked for the Shah to be extradited to be quote-unquote
tried for his crimes. And when they didn't do that, they stormed
the embassy. And that's when they started chanting death to America,
death to Israel, the great Satan, the little
The idea that cuz what she said there was lift the sanctions.
>> How is that a response to what was said?
>> I'm getting there. So, what she said there was lift
the sanctions, which can reduce the economic pressure on the
people, and then maybe they would have more like means
to fight back against the regime. Cuz what she said was she like
she kind of dodged the question of if she believes there should
be regime change cuz she's like, "Oh, I just don't think that
should be like our job. We should That should be their thing
to do." And I asked you this question earlier for that specific
reason. How the [__] do you get out from under the
oppressor by
You can't.
So, yes, it is up to the And that's why they're saying we're
not going to endorse a leader. You guys this year have to take
your destiny. But, sure. There is no way to do that. What do
you mean they're on their own?
>> They So, about 20 to 30 million sincere Shah Sincere
not Shah, but um sincere Shia Muslims in the country would support
the
How do you fight those people?
They have all of the weapons. They have all of the political
capital. They have every access to everything in the country.
There is no There are no boots on the ground. How do you >> Are
Are you assuming that Are you assuming the um sorry, the like
civilian
Muslim population kind of inherits the weaponry from the army
if the army gets
Like what is the kind of calcu- cuz cuz those are just also civilians,
right? >> I'm going to be the person who's like uncultured
and say, "Well, it is a militaristic religion, and it seems like
it leads to the most avid movements in the world so far. So,
I do believe that those people would be far more like militant,
far more extreme in the actions they'd be willing to take." >> For
sure. Yeah, no, that's that's reasonable. Um so, I do think you're
going to end up having these two factions uh basically like the
liberal-minded versus the religious-minded sides, which is the
whole conversation in general, right? That is the two. It is
a bipolar
situation. Um and so, yeah, the that 20-30 million people is
uh it's a predicament. It's a pickle, but it really is going
to have to come down to them being able to overthrow the like
establishment of whatever amount of um disabling or disarming
the military and getting them to submit, like I said. And at
that point
you Not to say you won't have people do fanatical [__]
as like retaliation,
but you can seize power
if an opportunity for that is given. But if no opportunity is
created, you will never end it. And the idea that you just What
she said was lift the sanctions, which translates to keep the
regime in power. And if you think you're going to sweet-talk
uh the Islamic extremist into just being like, "You know, the
Americans kind of got a good idea. Yeah, that's like let's just
be cool, man." Like that's again, it's very
it's just very disconnected and very naive and very like >> Saudi
Arabia right now, and that's why they're Westernizing to some
extent, why they're like integrating more cultural movements,
why they're becoming more progressive in their beliefs over time,
what they're willing to allow into their
>> Yeah, those are different countries in different states,
and I don't think the
I don't think one >> Saudi Arabia literally has been sanctioned
multiple times for trying to genocide the Yemenis, no? Like literally
like stopping them out? >> I'm not going to pretend to
be an expert on Saudi Arabia or even that many other countries
in [__] region. I obviously have a personal stake
in Iran because that's where the [__] my family's
from. So, I'm not going to stray outside of whatever the context
of my own knowledge to go making
next claims, but what I'm saying is that these people the conversation
is about whether these people in the country And she was saying
like, "Oh, these people don't want like pa- I don't think pa-
lobby coming in there." It's like there's a lot of assumptions
that she's making there that are kind of just not really correct.
And
she's basically again saying, "Hey, just walk back the sanctions.
Just let the regime survive."
In which case, if it's 20 to 30 million out of 93 million, that
means like 60
to 73 million people are opposed to the regime and they're stuck
under it,
Do we agree that's a majority of the
>> You you went too high with the numbers, but it's a majority
of the population. What if it was 50/50? Okay. If it was 50/50,
I mean
You're asking me democratically what do I think about that or
like what >> No, I'm asking you would it still be okay
to go in and and be willing to kill like all of those people
who are against you until they basically stop fighting? Like
at what point Like at some point you do need to like basically
show people a better way and hope they can change on their own
because there almost is no way to help.
Right? So, I'm saying like you're you're you're making the argument
that like it's the majority being like dominated by the minority
and it's like okay, I could maybe understand that, but it's like
what if it was 50/50? Does that make the oppression like okay
and now you can't get rid of it? It's like the oppression's probably
bad no matter what, right? >> Yes. Yes. Yes, absolutely.
I'm just saying that when it could becomes a question of like
um you know, what are the the two factions of the population
going to do at after this again imaginary outcome where the military
gets disabled. Um I'm saying that the people that are against
the regime far outnumber the people that are for the regime.
Uh now, for my own personal biases, if the regime is like the
Iranian regime, then yes, it's always appropriate to end that
regime. It's just
Again, you have to have reasons to do it. America's not just
going to run around the world doing regime change on every single
country unless it benefits them in some way, right? So, um but
what if the question is just should they be dismantled or like
uh >> Do you think Here's Here's another question. >> Or
for my own personal biases, yes. >> Do you think America
and Israel will ever allow Iran to be a power in any sense economically,
politically, militarily that rivals Israel in any >> Economically,
yes. Rivals, well, okay. In the context, are we talking about
in the context of a new regime that is pro-Israel? Like we had
prior? >> New regime that is like democrat Let's say it's
the ideal regime. >> Okay. My my my version of an ideal
thing. Um I think they will let them economically prosper. The
question of the military, I think they'll let them build a strong
military, but America and Israel are always going to want to
have Like we What was that doctrine you guys were pulling up
when you watching Fuentes where it's like you guys always have
to sell the best to Israel. Obviously, they're going to keep
them um secured from any potential threat that grows, but if
they have an Iran that like in the past was pro-Israel and
I don't think they have to fear that um that ally that they've
reinstated in the region. And if anything, they should have and
then make sure they never get taken over by Islam ever again.
>> So, they won't be a threat. They're They're an ally.
Like you would you want want strong allies in the region?
I understand the other theory people have say with >> with
China?
Oh, sorry. Sorry. Sorry. They uh have never wanted strong allies
in the
>> Okay, that's your perspective on Israel >> that
they have were like broken before they became allies.
When Egypt was strong, they were an >> I see. Um so, is
this a general philosophy that you feel like people don't want
to have strong allies in general around them or just Israel?
>> Um I think >> not saying that's a dismissal. I'm
just trying to ask you to get >> is a threat.
>> Okay. Okay. >> Um if they were further away, maybe
they're fine with it, right? They're probably totally fine with
the United States as an ally, right? But um Yeah, I think I think
people who are close by, I don't think they trust those >> why
why if I may ask, why is that? Cuz the United States could still
them in the ass, right? If they chose to, they could for sure
just go delete them. Um and just like we don't support you anymore
and just if they wanted to, they could. So, what is the reason
>> that they're they have no threat for the United States
when a significant portion of people in the United States think
Reza Pahlavi is entering that country in the next decade. >> Wait,
say that one more time. You don't think who I'm talking about
Israel and >> opposition in the United States when they
have people in the United in the United States convinced via
media that Reza Pahlavi will enter that country in the next decade.
So, I'm I'm basically saying that they realize they have total
narrative control, that nobody is like nobody in the US is turning
against them in a sincere way. Yeah. >> I see. I mean,
the last couple of years would be kind of back to different,
right? People they've been losing a lot of support in America.
They have really lost uh complete control of the narrative and
of their like plot armor as people kind of resent them for >> I
they I think I think they >> Am I just too tapped into
like >> getting it back and nobody is talking about it.
>> Getting it back through what? Just like the cool down
from it not being in people's like on their feed or like liking
them going to Iran.
>> of media with total approval from the Trump administration.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, that's yeah, that's definitely
Actually, that's a funny one. I posted it. I don't think we ever
watched it, but the 1976 the Shah talking about Israel and Palestine.
It's very funny to see how nothing has changed in 50 years. He's
talking about how they're controlling newspapers, media, finances,
banks and he's like, I'll stop myself there cuz he knows there's
more to it and Palestine is just whatever. He's like, they need
to stop backing Iran. >> about banks. I'm not talking about
banks. I don't know who I'm talking >> I'm just I'm just
telling you. I'm just telling you. It's them buying media things
is definitely not surprising and I I get what you're saying that
Okay, so they feel like they have control. >> I'm I'm not
even saying them. It's like not even it's just the biggest private
owner of the IDF is buying up all the media in America. It's
like as I'm sorry. It's like I don't have to I'm not hypothesizing
about a Jewish conspiracy or anything. It's just the biggest
IDF
is literally buying up a monopoly of media in the United States
and is being allowed to do so by a guy who is tremendously financially
benefiting from all of these things happening.
>> True. True. True. True. Okay, so so that's what makes
Israel okay with it is that they have like a stronghold enough
so that um and it's I guess from and far enough in the past where
it's not like BB's making that decision um to gain or You get
what I'm saying, right? Cuz my question was why they would like
be okay with this strong ally, but not want this other one >> Well,
and they also don't need the United States. Like they can't they
can't make America not be strong, right? In the in the short
term. >> Sure. Whereas they could inflict >> like
it's not like well, I actually have a I have an I have an aversion
to strong allies. So, I'm not going to I'm going to tell the
the who's way stronger than me to [__] off. That's
not really what happens, right? >> Yeah, no, no, I get
you. I just wanted to understand your perspective on why you
wouldn't want strong local allies. Again, given that these guys
have like thousands of years of history uh >> I saw BB
Netanyahu speaking Persian. Bro was speaking fluent Farsi talking
to like Iranian people like in announcements from this. It's
like this guy
>> There's no you don't just learn that for a language
of people that you hate. They They again, there was clearly a
prior to things getting completely which literally goes back
thousands of years. It's a [__] Cyrus, but
But yeah, I just I just I get what you're saying. I see what
you're saying even strategically. I'm not trying to say that's
all invalid. I just disagree.
Hold on, what's
Trying to think. Yeah, okay, okay.
>> Yeah, and and like they gave refuge to during World
War II and too. They originally wanted to stay neutral and then
America was like, "Yeah, we're using your [__] railways,
bro." Uh or the British or whoever the [__] it was,
but yeah, West said, "Yo, we need this path." And also they [__]
they refueled uh what was it? Was it the American um The Americans
needed to refuel and they were like getting choked off in the
region. Uh I'm like a loose on specific details, but they definitely
bro, they were goaded. They were super Western and they were
very pro-Israel. So, I just think Israel would be happy to create
that. And the question of whether they would like let them surpass
them, sure, maybe they would want to like limit them to not be
more powerful than Israel for a sense of security just in case
something ever went wrong in the future and they lost control
and then that new Islamic regime that takes over would then gain
access to that stuff and you know, [__] them over,
right? So,
you know, playing the long game, keeping that insurance policy.
I wouldn't disagree they would do that, but I don't think that
they want to uh starve Iran from becoming a new like economic
superpower or uh whatever, prosperous nation in that region and
change the entire like politics of the region. Also, decapitating
the funding for Hamas and just going over and killing people
in Israel. It's like
There's a lot of layers to it. >> Uh are you If my wife
of you come on, you could definitely talk cuz you've done way
more research into this than me. I get a lot of my opinions from
you. I I won't I won't jump into the conversation. You can make
the arguments you want to make. If you want to come on, but if
you don't want to come on, it's fine. Yeah, my wife is like super
informed on this stuff. She's been following a lot of this stuff.
>> True that. True that. >> she's probably not even
disagreeing with you. Like she probably agrees that the people
were super when they protested. Like obviously she was tracking
a whole bunch of this stuff. I think she just probably has a
totally different view of how Iranians view the Shah. >> Yeah,
I think I I just saw like a quick message in passing cuz I've
been To be honest, I'm not really reading chat a ton to not get
distracted, but something about his grandpa being a Nazi or something
like that. It's like Obviously I don't think that's awesome.
Wait, also he said his granddad was a Nazi? >> Uh sympathizer.
>> Of what age? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, oh, yeah, no,
the the dad of the Like yeah, no, I know exactly who she's talking
about. I know exactly who she's talking about. Yeah, that was
like in '51 and '52 or whatever and yeah, that was a That guy
was a character. I don't like that But that guy has nothing to
do with the golden age. The golden age starts in '63 to '79.
That's where um the Pahlavi name becomes this kind of you know,
time to return to is after the white revolution when they started
like hyper accelerating
to mimic the West and then Yeah, I don't know if you've seen
I don't know if you've seen footage of Iran in the '60s and '70s
and I don't know if you've seen that like massive celebration
where they got a bunch of royalty and people >> coming
stuff, yeah. >> Yeah, just in general they were just free
and western, right? They were just like not wearing bedsheets.
>> They were free and we- Were they free and western?
>> Yes, literally. Just >> I could have said Was
the Shah not a an authoritarian leader?
What do you think I mean when I say
like free to free to self-determine.
They were given Okay. way more freedoms and way more rights and
the second revolution happened like women got kicked out of the
army, they all kicked out of government, they just completely
got
literally raped into second-class citizens. Um
Like I I'm not going to pretend that every single thing connected
to the Pahlavi name is like perfection, but you it really
I I just think it's like an overwhelmingly positive perspective
to the again to that '63 to '79 era which was
where things went wrong and the mistakes seemed to or started
to be made. >> Am I live? How's it going? >> I get
why you think the things that you do. Um >> Based? You
got me wrong, based.
>> At the very least >> didn't mean to cut you off.
>> Uh well, I I think what you said just a second ago while
I was listening um cuz you were saying that like the golden age
is kind of the marker of when the Shah starts. I think that's
important. Um >> Oh, when it got good. I should say or
like the the time that's reminisced or um romanticized in the
past. >> Yeah. I just don't Yeah. >> Definitely romanticized
um because the the Shah um in like the '30s, right? Was doing
some pretty um horrific stuff to the Yeah. >> the religious
community and and and stuff like that. Like they're >> I
believe that 100%. >> Yeah, it honestly I I look at um
the way that uh Khomeini and Khamenei both like ran the country
as being very um reminiscent of of the Shah because >> Of the
grandpa? You You mean of the grandpa um Pahlavi, right? Like
the three-generations back? >> Or even under uh Reza Reza
Shah, right? >> Sure. Sure.
>> The second one or like the dad of current guy. I get
you. They all have the same name. It's super hard [laughter]
to distinguish.
>> Yeah. So but even under um So even under his dad, right?
Like I I don't think that um the I'm just going to call him like
little Pahlavi cuz it's just different for easier. Like the current
the current guy that's hanging around I don't think that he would
be anything like his his dad or or grandfather, but the way that
people
remember at least you know, and it's not even like you have to
go as crazy with it like the MEK position which is
I don't do you know the MEK at all like in terms of some of the
weird [__] that they get up to? >> No, if if
you can give me like a whatever 30-second
>> Yeah. But I don't know I'm not sure what you're referring
to. >> They're an Islamic
communist group that sided with
Saddam during the Iran-Iraq War in the '80s. So they like track
record's really bad, but anyway, they're against the Shah. They
lobby the American government against the Shah, but also against
the Islamic regime. So they're you know, they're around a lot,
but I
I would just say that Yeah. Yeah, I mean they're just one of
one of two Iranian kind of lobby interests in the US, but
I think a lot of people remember
the Shah as as being like a pretty bad time. I know my dad >> clarify,
you're referring to Oh, sorry. You said your dad, so you're talking
about the '60s, '70s range or >> Before then. Like
>> Okay, so
>> If I can clarify, 0% of what I'm talking about is like
Oh, I loved
you know, Pahlavi's the the the the dynasty's actions prior to
'53 or prior to I mean '53 is really where it starts to shift.
Then '63 is like the actual like that's when things start to
pop off, the White Revolution, the like Family Protection Act,
all that type of
That's the version. It's '63 to '79 is the only thing that I'm
saying like that's what people want to return to, which is where
they left off, right? That you know what and I know you can't
go backwards in time, but it's kind of like symbol and that's
why also it's not about making him be ruler.
>> What about the 60s? >> Like even in the 60s like
the in terms of the white revolution, a lot of the the like land
reforms that were happening were being done very very much
like hurt the religious community in the
It it basically like it's like I think about like sacking of
the temples that Nero did. Not to that degree, obviously, but
like you know. >> They but I I mean that in a way is it
was literally like wealth redistribution, right? They're like
these people that are illiterate and just like like the Dalits,
right? We're going to give them the like free education to learn
how to read. The army went in and started teaching people how
to write and [__] And then we have to give them land
so they can like build a life because the clerics and stuff have
like a monopoly. So I get what you're saying that it's like the
religious people didn't like that, but I'm kind of just I'm okay
with that. Like that's [clears throat] to me the close that the
whatever is moving that country to be more like the West in general,
um, I think is better for the people in the country. I think
it's better for the whole world because whatever I obviously
prefer Western values and Western countries and I would never
choose to live in another one. That's what I'm saying. So that's
why with her she's like, um, taking issue with a behavior from
and I'm not trying to say it's like oh it's so long ago it doesn't
matter. I'm saying in those transitionary phases where they redistributed
power from the religious people to the rest of the people, I
get that that would be upsetting for the religious people, but
I think that was a net positive and like a virtuous act. >> Unfortunately,
it >> it's going to be uncomfortable for some people, though,
right? >> Yeah, well even even just like in terms of the
as a direct consequence of
those actions, right? We we got the the 1978 79
like revolution, right?
>> That well, you're saying the 79 thing that I mean that
and that like um land is >> Like in terms of um you get
what I'm saying like in in terms of Khomeini's
um >> Yeah, all of the all of the resentment for the Shah
eventually culminated at the I I I agree with that for sure.
And um but again, there's that it becomes complicated cuz one,
you have a population that went from like one to 50% literacy
in a like very short time span. They have no historical knowledge,
they have no like political like literacy, and then they're in
an environment where we know there was an American coup for '53,
and there was I would say quite certainly um and even whatever.
There's basically MI6, there's other intelligence agencies that
were involved in fomenting the revolution. Also, the fact that
Khomeini was flown in on a French plane with journal like
there was some [__] going on where
that was not Again, where people are saying this is not a natural
protest, that was also not a like completely
organic natural protest. And so >> No, in the '70 um in
'78 that's uh like sorry, I should clarify. In '78, those protests
were more organic. What happens in 1979 is you see um you know,
Khomeini doing a lot of that uh kind of external meddling um
and then coming back >> Sending tapes in and all that type
of stuff. Well, that's that's how it culminated, but just in
the the general disdain for the Shah. Again, I'm not saying this
guy was perfect, obviously. And he was definitely um like you
know, more strict than I would ever expect any Western country
to be. Um but again, I think his circumstances were different.
And I think the fact that we ended up with the last 47 years
is the exact justification of why um he needed to be. And in
fact, he should have been more
he should have been more
adamant about not letting
like Iran slip into the darkness. And And in a way the the states
kind of let him down by just abandoning him in the end. Um especially
after being the ones that put him in that position in the first
place how many years prior. So Yeah, it's it's like there's a
lot of different compounding factors, but I saw someone in chat
saying that I said he ushered in the golden age. Yeah, he he
literally did. That's
Bro forced the White Revolution and people call that the golden
age uh of Pahlavi Dynasty.
>> I have a question for you I guess about your assessment
in in terms of um some of the activity that I guess maybe is
happening now, but uh specifically under the Shah. Like obviously
um Mosaddegh was involved with um kind of kicking the British
out of >> Yeah, nationalizing the oil.
>> Um but how how do you feel about um like Pahlavi's dad
um
pursuing nuclear technology and and that kind of thing to the
detriment of
like just even in terms of infrastructure. Like obviously a lot
of the modernization happened really in these um like cities,
right? Like Tehran obviously versus all of it. Yeah. >> Yeah,
it's definitely started at like the capital and metropolitan
areas. Yeah, for sure. >> Because like the rural communities
inside the country >> you're talking about nuclear there.
Was that just like in general do I support it or are you saying
that they [__] something up? I I feel like there's
something I missed there you were talking about with uh the nuclear
thing. What I support them having
in general or >> Was modernization at the expense of um
like the common person that was happening? Um and I think for
uh and you you kind of see it repeat almost like a carbon copy
with uh the current regime, right? Like obviously it's significantly
worse because of all these secondary sanctions that have eventually
uh come to happen or come to pass. Um but early early on
a lot of the modernization efforts and a lot of the
like mass industrialization was really only taking place in these
small areas. So, part of the water crisis that's going on right
now has
has like its foothold basically in some of the
like pipe I'm not like a a plumbing person or a urban planner,
but my >> The the infrastructure from back then is, you
know, having issues down the >> royally like me there's
fresh water um lakes that are totally extinct and stuff now,
right? >> Yeah. I I would say they've had the um control
of the environment there for 47 years. I'm going to have to blame
that on the the dudes who have who have been there cuz that's
like a if you took it in '79
I can't really look at it issues from now and be like, "Oh, that
guy from, you know, 40 years ago or 50 years ago um it's his
fault that you guys don't have good water in 2026."
>> No, for sure for sure and and obviously you know, there
are there are old um like tribal practices of of bringing water
down from the mountain that were totally abandoned. You can still
see the
uh they're they're called I think it whatever the word in Persian
is, but you can see them on maps like they're these giant
irrigation uh pits basically. >> Right. Right. >> You
know, there there are things that were happening that um you
know, might have been salvageable,
basically it's like everything Yeah. Yeah, everything has has
been left to rot. So, even when there was a lot of modernization
and Westernization happening like things
um I don't know. The way I look at it is
things weren't great.
And then things were like really not
so, that's what I if I can jump in for a second, that's like
there's maybe one or two points that I wanted to ask you. It's
So, one um again, they're they're growing it from like however
uh primitive we'll call it at at 1950 and obviously it was even
just tip more up before that. But, 1950 it's like it's you know,
'53 is where that coup is going to happen. 10 years later is
where the hyper modern hyper modernization is going to happen
and also like the amount of oil that he was starting to pull
and the amount of money he had. Like you like it was he was making
a statement on the global stage that like, "Yo, we're rich as
[__] and our army is strong as fuck." Which is obviously
a big part of why they wanted him out in '79. Uh which also goes
back to what Jizzy was saying earlier about like, "Do I think
Israel would want that?" Even America at the time was like, "Yeah,
those Iranians are getting too strong. We We got to go regime
change, regime change." But, um but so just pulling back for
a second,
so so they were like you're saying it wasn't that good uh in
like the '60s, '70s or whatever. But, again that is like the
next step up the stairs from how it was prior. So, yes there's
still a bunch of issues. Yes, there's still like infrastructural
issues and this leads to the other point that the um the dispersion
of the wealth um or distribution, sorry, of the wealth. So, you're
saying like a lot of the investments and growth is happening
in uh you know, major cities.
>> But, prior to prior to that it's like it was literally
just like villages and farmers. Like it was is very
very primitive, right? It's like very um underdeveloped in a
way that it's I Again, this is part of the whole like fomenting
resentment against the king thinking like, "Oh, he's like keeping
all the money for himself." Or like, "You know, those rich yuppies
in the city." And all this. Um but realistically it's you're
trying to build up a nation um from like the ground to become
basically actually a global superpower. That was really the intention.
Um and like an economic superpower. Basically uh imitating whatever
the major cities of the other major Western nations.
>> And I feel like if
maybe you give me let me know if you agree with this, but I think
if he was still there or that, you know, we continued down that
road for 47 years, I think that development and growth would
continued out from those major cities into creating a more like
overall prosperous land. And again, like the because of the wealth
disparity was a thing, which that kind of relative difference
is always going to be,
you know, something that pushes people to things like revolution
um and then and a frustration to push for revolution. But >> Yeah,
it's just it's like the >> the their lives were I want
to say clearly better than they ever were afterwards. And uh
sorry, one more point. You talked about the
>> Do you would you agree that the sanctions started So,
okay. The revolution happens in '79. The Shah is in America.
Khomeini ex- says he'll extradite him over here. We want to try
him for his crimes, which I translate that to we want to torture
and kill him, but whatever. And the US said, "No, go [__]
yourself." And then that's when they Well, they had already stormed
the embassy a couple times, but that's when they went in and
actually took all the
>> And they kept them for like whatever, 2 years or like
444 days, blah blah blah. It was 20 minutes after the inauguration
that they made the deal. All that thing. Sorry to go into so
much detail. But um
it was like almost 2 years. If you look at the currency, the
currency was frozen in '79
and it from like 70 rial or whatever, right? And then in '81,
basically after that um crisis was over and they got the hostages
back, Iran's request or like their demands to give the hostages
back was like, "You guys [__] off and keep your hands
out of our business." They were like requesting the isolation
or the separation, right? That was That was their their ask.
>> Um so >> Yeah, so it's like those sanctions started
happening cuz they
shh abducted the people at the embassy and said, "Death to America
and go [__] yourself. Don't like we don't want you
in our >> Yeah. country." So, >> It's It's hard for
me to blame America like, "Oh, they're like choking them with
sanctions." It's like they they kind of they kind of started
it and and and kept it going and and that that that ethos of
America hasn't gone anywhere really, right? They're it's not
>> No. No, for sure. And I like in terms of economic measures
taken against the country in in the 20th century, like I probably
I like obviously you can't take
um and hold them for years. Like that's obviously just um that's
that's behavior that's not >> terrorism, right? That's
like we >> Yeah, yeah. It's um >> Sorry, I don't
mean to interrupt you >> No, no, no. Um obviously it's
like horrific. Um and for a long time um in response like um
the only there there's like a hypocrisy and then um the Americans
working with Iran against Iraq in the war, but they were also
working with Iraq against the Iranians in the war. Like there's
a lot of bipolar like
>> '91? The that old thing? >> Uh no, no. Uh in in
the mid-80s.
Um cuz uh the Americans were doing logistics like aerial um logistics
and helping the Iranians uh fight part of um the Iran-Iraq War.
>> Oh, sorry. Iran-Iraq. Not the Iraq-Kuwait. Never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. >> Yeah, not
the Gulf, but um >> I was going to Sorry. I was My brain
went to a It's just a weird coincidence. Forgive me for a side
note. Uh the Gulf War ended also on February 28th, literally
the year I was born, and then this war started the day again
my birthday but a different year. Anyways, it was just like and
we live in a simulation, bro. But Sorry, you were talking about
the Iran-Iraq War. I I I >> Yeah, so like >> But
yes, they're definitely hypocrites. They're definitely hypocrites.
>> 100%.
Um I find it I find it also >> Multiple crews in different
directions. >> Yeah, exactly. Well, and and I feel like
that's probably where all of this spells disaster, right? Cuz
it's like every If you go in every 37 years and like do something
stupid in a country, like um you see this happen uh like clockwork
every every two decades with Yemen um and the Americans. It's
like very um it's very strange how it just keeps happening. Um
and nobody that's like >> stability. Whether that's intentional
or not is a whole other I don't know, but but I get your point
that it's like it's stayed up and they kind of have to keep running
back and trying to clean the mess up and uh yeah. That's what
that's the concern with Iran, right? Is we don't want another
mess and another Iraq. We don't want like basically things to
become uh chaos, which is like death and chaos as opposed to
order and I mean >> uh death, I guess. It's like it's still
a person, but yeah. >> A potential worse cuz things can
always get worse. >> In the summer, uh cuz Pahlavi was
doing um some of his uh like calls for people to defect. I was
pretty supportive of his um his initial
his initial soft basically that he he was saying during the 12-day
war. Um I guess was that this summer or the summer before? Anyways,
time time is weird. >> Yeah, it's all [laughter] a blur.
It was like 7 8 months ago. Yeah. >> It's like mental.
Um but it So, in that context, I was like, "Okay, I support you
know, it was was like good. I'm I'm glad there's someone." Cuz
the other um in in terms of like external people, uh there's
really only like I think three of them um of like
maybe pro-American or pro-Western
um defectors that have any kind of uh pull. One of them is uh
Rohava Rohavi, whatever her name is. Uh the MEK lady. One of
them is Pahlavi and there's like a really strange uh former IRGC
guy who I I don't know what to make of, but um there's three
[clears throat] of them. He's the only one that has done anything
somewhat normal. Um but then all of a sudden in December he's
starting to do this um
He's like, "No, I I I mean, I could lead a transitional government."
It's like, "Dude, what is Okay. >> From the IRGC to I don't
know. I don't
>> Well, and and Pahlavi it's like, okay, so what are we
saying? Everyone wants to run the country and none of the people
who are saying that, "Well, I want to run the country." have
lived there for
for decades. So, >> What So, there's a quick There's a
quick question as well. Well, on one hand I get that they're
not living there idea, but in a large way it's like they're trying
to create a constitutional democracy with separation of church
and state. They're very much trying to mimic the American model,
which the American model mimicked the old Persian model, right?
Um so,
the the thing with the transitionary government um and I myself,
I don't know about you, like I I don't I'm not opposed to it,
but I'm not sitting here like, "Yes, Pahlavi should be the leader
of the country." I think he should just be a symbolic figurehead
that represents going back to where they kind of up and then
moving forward again as a country. Uh but that again and also
just having like the organizing power to have enough of a kind
of like coordinated effort on like that the day after plan, right?
Like the 100-day plan plan to create a referendum and election
environment and then people have to run their parties. Like there's
a bunch of things have to happen before you can even have the
election. So, just having him be there as like, "Yo, I left to
go to whatever like pilot school and then my dad whatever got
exiled. I'm and I get that it's like, "Oh, but he hasn't lived
here." I don't know that that matters though. Um cuz again, the
person that's going to end up actually being the democratic democratically
elected leader would be someone or I I should say
it would it would need to at least be someone who ends up deciding
to live in the country moving forward, right? Whether they like
left long time ago and now they can return, uh but they're like
going to live in Iran cuz that's where uh serving in office,
right? Um but other Yeah, I just like I it's not really a disqualifying
factor
because again, it's like we live in a global
environment and the people who are trying to overthrow the regime
are trying to reconnect to that Western thing, which is where
he lived. If anything, he's just like the most qualified to bring
American values into that country.
>> Well, I I don't even know that um
like in ter- in terms of American values, I don't actually even
see that as being like a a missing component of the country right
now. Like obviously,
I'll [clears throat] do a small caveat there. Um in terms of
democracy, like although it hasn't been respected, right? I mean,
the the you can start looking at like the um the election in
2009 and then how that was handled.
like it's [clears throat] the same. >> Yeah, yeah, cuz
I mean, they they still have some very limited elected officials.
And again, like it's not free and fair elections. >> I
I was going to say, so that's >> That's the that's kind
of the problem I have with even the concept of saying that they
have elections. I know what you mean in like an objective people
go have ballots, but these people are filtered through a grand
council of half appointed ayatollahs and they have 100% veto
power on anything that gets decided by the government. They're
It's like you are religiously curating those leaders. So, you're
sure you're going to get the >> itself doesn't have the
values necessarily, but the people
the people themselves
understand and participate as, you know, to the best of their
ability in democracy. So, like >> Oh, oh, sorry. I I didn't
>> That form is still there. Yeah. >> so sorry, I
didn't mean bring American values as in like the people don't
have it uh cuz I think the people do have and they want to get
back to being able to live that way. I meant that him being the
transitional government to creating like a constitutional
government environment, which can then have those elections,
which aren't filtered through a religious cabinet. Just and then
>> can I just ask like Well, I just want to ask a question.
Like foundationally,
given that his father is the person who explicitly ended the
democracy in Iran,
why would you think that he is a good
like jump >> do you mean he ended the democracy?
>> That the Shah seized power with a like US UK backed
coup after World War II. >> But he he was already still
the monarchy above that. He was He was already still a one-party
system. >> monarchy where they had like a parliament and
stuff. >> Yeah. [clears throat] Yeah. >> ended all
of that. He concentrated all power onto himself.
Uh that's not true. He He concentrated the military power to
And he might have had that veto that level of veto. I'm not saying
you should reinstate the veto power power on Pahlavi, though.
Like I said, he's completely symbolic.
But um yeah, the king or the Shahanshah,
he had a one-party system, which like I said was able to be both
men and women. Um but he only kind of took over for that one
prime minister. He didn't dismantle the whole system or like
take control of everything. Um >> But the legislative process
in in in the
did he not do
like he he basically
redid the entire
legislature, did he not? In the '60s, like '63? >> I I
believe so. I don't know what like the details on that shift,
but
>> Was '75 the Family Protection Act? >> No. No.
No. No. Like he basically eroded the the entire political landscape,
I believe, in 1975
um cuz it >> In what way?
>> Um like
filed under um what was it the not not the Raja party um Ra Rasta
Rastakiz? >> Are they Rastafari?
Sorry, I don't have to cut you off. I'm not sure if >> not
Ra not Raja not Rasta um
No, they my understanding was he basically like everyone was
then under a
political branch like under a single
>> Yeah, it was Yeah, I'm saying it was a uni-party. Like
it was one party. >> I'm sorry, I didn't I didn't mean
uni-party like two parties that actually just are like secretly
one party. Like people say about America like oh they're all
working for military whatever. Um I it was literally like this
is the government the only party and it's the party underneath
the king for sure which again primitive 1950s 60s and coming
but again, you're comparing this to what was before that which
is way more [__] up and what was after that which
was way more [__] up. That's not saying that he was
perfect but he was absolutely the best thing that Iran has experienced
in the last 100 and like 50 years.
Um and obviously the context of life was way different past that
where technology just didn't exist. Uh so it's like a kind of
a whole other conversation but >> Don't you feel like if
he allowed the country to remain a democracy, he could have like
provided the same guidance and recommendations but let the people
like
>> Uh sorry, ask that question one more
>> So he basically like he basically concentrated all power
onto himself after the uh the coup. Right? All the power was
concentrated onto him. Don't you think like if he basically just
said like hey, we're doing this and I'm like basically going
to let you guys run the country. So it's like another constitutional
thing but he actually gives them like demo democratic power.
He actually lets them decide things. Don't you think that would
have worked out better for everybody? >> People still had
the ability to vote on who was in parliament. There was still
a democratically elected group. It was that there was one party,
not multiple
That's what it is. And he was even supportive to Muslims, too.
What do you mean? Okay, I'm saying it What's the actual or what's
your correction?
he had all military control and I believe he still had all the
powers of the of the monarch as well, right?
>> Yeah, he wasn't directly controlling >> but towards
towards the ending of it of reign, he was actually
To my understanding, he was giving power at that point more to
the government because it was like, "Okay, I'm just going to
step back and be the figurehead." And basically shift it
yeah, him not being as directly in control of things. That was
In that last couple years, actually Yeah, now that I think about
it, Maywan, I feel like my information is directly contradicting
yours. And I'm not trying to call you wrong cuz I'm whatever.
I'm just pulling it from, you know, 100 documentaries and all
this type of [__] But um to my understanding, the
closer it got to '79, he was actually giving power, not consolidating
more of it. 53 to then, yes. >> in the uniparty >> I
think people could just apply to run. You just like you had elections.
>> Like it Yeah, it was still um like in terms of the
>> They were allowed to vote. Sorry, go on. >> No,
no. And and obviously like women women voting is important, but
Sorry, what were you saying? >> flip onto the son of the
Shah cuz apparently Mohammad Reza Pahlavi had the nickname Light
of the Aryans. Let's go. Suddenly we're on team Shah now, guys.
>> great white hope. Let's go. Bro, we're just tanned white
people. Come on. Let's work together [laughter] here. We got
to >> Persians are basically kind of >> I'm I'm like
half kidding, but also not We got polluted with Arabs. That's
why we're all like a bunch of us are super >> Okay, chill,
chill, chill. >> Sorry, sorry. [laughter] >> No poisoning
the blood, Jesus Christ.
>> I didn't say it. >> I have it in my blood, don't
worry. When I say some of us, I'm talking about myself. I'm literally
like, bro, cuz my cousin's got like zero body hair and I'm like,
yo, how could I have the had those genes? That would have been
way more
>> Well, in the Persian it obviously it's like a really
important um power in that region, but um no, I think I think
largely like the um
the way that we're talking about it, like there were still other
political dissidents that were being jailed at that time because
they Yeah, because they they they were like, we don't want to
be under um >> Is it Am I correct in saying that um
>> Yeah, yeah. Am I correct in saying that um these were
communist parties that he was like, I'm not going to let communism
grow in my country. >> Yeah, one of them definitely was.
Um I think it would have was like the National Front. Um >> There's
a name that's evading my mind right now that's like the notorious
communist party that I would refer to right now, but it's like
completely I'm drawing a blank, so I apologize. >> No,
no, it's and it's okay. >> they're in that kind of Oh,
Tudeh, thank you, Red Ain't Dead. You got me. You got >> Got
me there. The Tudeh Party. >> and there were So some of
them some of them were definitely around and um maybe maybe not
great and obviously the Americans were doing a lot of um prompting,
like, hey, crack down on those guys specifically.
Cuz they didn't want any Russian um Soviet communist influence
in the country at >> Yeah, that's And again, I'm I'm sorry,
go on, go on, go on. >> Yeah. No, I I just anytime that
the Americans are getting involved and again, it's not um I listen,
no fan of the Soviets in that region doing period, right? Like
not uh not good guys, um but it just I'm terrified that at the
end of all of this bombing that's happening right now, they're
going to look at it and say, "Oops, we killed everybody." Which
is what Trump said today basically that there's um according
to him there's no Well, he basically said that everyone was at
that meeting. Um >> Yeah. Yeah, oh bro. >> how many
was meeting in person? Jesus, it's it's just so [__]
stupid. >> like not taking America seriously and just being
like, well, I guess it's Israel in this case. And just being
like, we're going to be above ground all in the same room. Like,
bro, how many times do you have to be
>> How many times does this 7-day war have to happen to
you for you to realize like, hey, if you ever collectivize somewhere
where you put enough resources in a place, Israel will take that
opportunity every time. They don't care. Yeah, like how many
times are you going to get your entire air force destroyed or
your entire political apparatus wiped out? I don't know. >> in
one Bro, I thought when he's like, "Oh, we got in seconds or
in like one shot." I thought he meant like we sent a bunch of
missiles that had a bunch of targets and they were all like locked
in. And I was talking to my parents about that earlier. They're
like, "Oh, the reason they waited that long was cuz they knew
they're going to be in this room and they could just murk 48
of them at one time." It was like, "Let's go." USA, USA.
>> Oh, man. >> No, it's um
You know, but so in there is one person,
I got COVID last month and still dying. >> Sorry to hear
that. >> I know, >> it's okay. I'll survive. But
like Larijani is still around and Barak Ravid who's been I don't
I don't know if he's like an Israeli journalist who's pretty
close with a bunch of like the political
guys on that side, but he was like, "Oh, this guy Larijani, like
he's someone that we could tap in." And he was like
he's not a um
God, it's like anytime someone suggests a new person, it's like
you look you look for 2 seconds and it's like that person is
a terrible idea. Um >> Even for a new leader of the country
or >> Yeah, yeah. >> Oh, yeah. I I get you. >> Everyone
is is suggesting like new people and you know, obviously, do
we want uh for for there to be like an IRGC
hardliner to be uh to take any kind of control, but that's who's
there right now. Um so, >> it's like What are we doing?
>> I I don't know um in practice if this is like contradictory
to
the constitution that they're trying to create or the democratic
environment they're trying to create, but I almost feel like
there has to be a limit to Actually, yeah, it's the separation
of church and state. It's like you might have you can practice
your religion in your own time, but that has to be like um built
into the country now in a way that can't be changed, that you
can't be then making the government into an Islamic uh organization,
right? >> Well, I mean, yeah.
>> So, in terms of um trying to do a shift like that, I
think
like I I know obviously like the the quote-unquote Islamic Republic
part of the government isn't like super popular with people living
there and I have a couple of friends um who who like live inside
the country still um that I've been chatting with. >> they're
not super popular with the people in the country? >> Yeah,
like the the um the IRGC component, obviously, like that uh the
Guardian Council's and everything else, like that's not popular.
The shell's not that's not like a thing, it's not popular, but
at the same time like I think there's enough religious people
within the country that some form of
system is is probably the most likely thing to happen still.
Um >> Mm, okay. Okay.
>> I don't know if that's um >> What do you mean,
okay? I said that same thing and you were like, you're a
So, how about you push back in the same >> I No, well,
I'm I'm just I'm being respectful. I'm trying I'm not going to
be like, "Who do you think is something different than me?"
>> Yeah, no, I just I obviously Again, and I'm also working
off of hopeium that like because there's a larger majority of
whatever, 60, 70 million
non-Muslims versus the 20 or 10 or 20 that were or was it 20,
30? Regardless, that it's the majority is leaning away from it.
So, I have to basically,
you know, again, I'm still praying to the gods and the fact that
this even happened is like we're living in a once-in-a-lifetime
moment. So,
Yeah, it's like I have to just hope that they're able to get
capture power and then have the referendum and
kind of like in state into the country
this separation of church and state that has to then be maintained
through, you know, this is the military whatever. >> Okay,
I think she was Were you hearing that 89% number and concerned
about that, Milan? >> Yeah, yeah, I'm not really surprised
by that number.
So, I'll have to pull up sources. So, we were talking earlier
earlier about like the percentage of support for Pahlavi. I wanted
to try and get some percentages. And so, I, you know, full disclosure,
I was asking AI like what percentage of Iranians in the country
are showing support for Pahlavi.
And then I I should have I didn't have the time whatever. I didn't
look further into it yet. This was like a thing in passing. But
from that it said 30% of people support him as a leader, 49%
support him as a transitional leader, and but 89% of people want
a democratic system in general as opposed to the
>> Is it a
Gamaan poll by any chance? Like G A M A
I don't want to be conflating something that's familiar, but
I'll just I'll re- I'll see if I can pull it up. I should be
able to go to my uh Google AI history or data stuff, right? And
then it should be like a second I should I got it be there >> Yeah,
cuz I think um like democracy is kind of like a Yeah, I I I think
democracy would would be popular itself.
But I know so there is a a pollster
or a group that does at least a fair amount of surveying within
Iran. I don't know about um all of their
survey style, but it's it's pretty difficult to get
like accurate data in any country where there's a fair amount
of repression, right? Let alone something >> It's it's
yeah. It's like you'll get killed for saying you're like I don't
like these guys. It's like okay, you just faded. >> No,
100%. So I think like democracy would be an an easy one. I think
most people um would say like yes, pro-democracy if if anything
maybe that 89%
figure would be an underrepresentation
of of how much but [laughter] >> Okay, wait, so >> Do
you think even more than 89% want at least a democratic >> I
don't know system that's like with separation of church and state
assuming you mean that as well, right? >> But like is that
them describing their ideal preference absent anything else or
is that like cuz it's a very different question from like do
we want democracy to we're going to be willing to kill off a
lot of people here for democracy? >> No, exactly. >> you
can't you can't be having to purge the millions or whatever.
That's like that would be just literally doing what the Khomeini
did years ago. >> No, exactly. >> You have to you
have to make it voted in and then just basically like >> Netanyahu
just tipped five >> acts as people >> Peep sake JSTOK,
what is the stream get these apps >> I'll put it in content
links. This I don't know if there's a more recent one, but um
>> Very rude.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Oh, it was it was Gamon by the way.
>> Oh, oh no.
>> Oh, it was calling you both and I don't even know what
that means, but I just said >> He got
I don't know what that is. >> It's supposed to be called
a
>> I think it's
>> Hey, what is What does Gamaan mean? >> Yeah, what's
the You were saying that source? Is it a good or bad source in
your eyes? >> I haven't I haven't done any looking at like
how they survey or anything else. It's just it's >> Yeah,
it's just kind of the only one that I know. >> Okay, so
that's actually the only source that you have as something available
to >> In terms of like survey
>> Yeah, yeah. >> Like I I don't I I just don't
Yeah, yeah. Well, in in in terms of
Like genuinely, I have no They're They're saying 20%
support the continuation of the Islamic Republic. Like they're
saying
majority want a different political system such as a secular
republic, a constitutional monarchy, or a more decentralized
democracy. I don't know how they're
If like if that was all one question, that's a confusing question.
It's not good survey data, but
>> Oh, I So I just went to the um Well, there's like this
What is this huge report? Iran's political preferences in 2020
2024. That's >> Uh kind of out of date. >> Well,
it would be >> it does still say around 70% oppose the
continuation of the Islamic Republic. So, and the highest level
opposition 81% occurred during the women life freedom uprising,
which is obviously the Masih Alinejad. So, um yeah, if it's 70
and 81 then and now there's been another like 32,000 plus people
killed, I would believe 89 or like you're saying even potentially
above. My concern when you asked about Gamaan was that like oh,
did I just get a really bad source? But so, okay. That is basically
all that we
Yeah, at least like this is the only one that I know about at
the very least. Um >> If you are looking for a video that's
okay to put on um I dropped one in the Iran protest and updates.
It's not a link, though.
>> I was just like some of the stuff from today. But
>> Oh, by the way, my one You might be able to help me.
You know like I'm going to I'm going to butcher her name, but
like Ahmadi- Ah- madinejad, the the journalist who's had like
multiple assassination attempts on her and
basically like those those
you know, Iranian activists or like the people um cuz I was tell-
I was trying to tell Jessica earlier, but I didn't want to go
like trying to fish for an exact quote in an interview that I
haven't already like pre-curated. That's just a waste of time,
right? Um but are you able to back me up on the claim that
Iranians have been very literally asking Trump to intervene militarily
and through bombing specifically target targeted military strikes.
Not saying like please flatten my neighborhood, obviously. Like
that Hasan [__] caricature of it is like no one's
saying kill my grandpa so I or I'll you know, kill myself type
of thing. It's a goofy way to phrase it, but um Yeah, so how
do you are Have you also at least been seeing what I'm referring
to? >> Yeah, well I think um uh like my one friend basically
he just you know, the way he says it it's like something eventually
has to like something going the way that we have been going.
It's like something
>> has to break. >> break. Um I I don't
>> like um and it's been a few days since I've spoken to
him. I'm a little bit worried cuz I haven't heard from him,
you know, I it's one of those things where I think that
a change is
needed. People are asking for help. >> is footage from
Iran. >> help. Um but I I don't know if that normally like
without Trump having like he cuz he prompted
um some of that, I think, when he was saying, "Oh, Iran, don't
kill those protesters or else you're going to have a have a red
reasons and I can't read and I can't read and I can't read and
I can't read and I can't read and I can't read and I massacre
of at least 30,000 people. Um like insane violence that happens
and nothing. No response.
Um and then he's talking about
>> Yeah. Yeah, like >> So here's the thing with that.
I I fully and even Reza Pahlavi also gets the same criticism
cuz he's like, "Go out into the streets 8:00 tonight." It's like
you literally told them what time to go out and kill people,
bro. >> I lied. I lied. I lied. This is all in Iran. This
is all in Iran. All of these are in Iran. >> just like
Generally he seems like a pretty intelligent dude.
in the in the West I know that obviously that those videos were
like they they were being circulating like crazy. Um but like
outside of him saying like or make noise in your house at um
>> Well, that was the more recent. I think that was the
more Oh, maybe he also said that in that old one. I don't want
to I don't want to be too precise. [__] that up.
>> they specifically started um cuz HRANA which is like
a human rights um organization that normally is tracking like
executions in the country like prisoner
um prison-based executions.
Um so they were they were talking about the increase in home
surveillance, right? Um happening after that. But um generally
speaking like I I don't think that people were
necessarily
uh responding
to that so much as there had been already I think like a week
of really large protests. >> It was already from like the
New Year's. It Yeah, exactly. Like the day of Oh, sorry. December
29th, I think. It definitely like all New Year's the night I
was just like looking at my Instagram and I was like, "Okay,
Iran's on fire." >> The The question is again, do we have
like um large-scale support for Trump bombing Iran even if it's
just bombing military targets? >> I don't I don't know
that they would normally like I think >> I just mean this
time during this
I like I don't think it's necessarily like a Trump support saying
but I think that people would have been happy like if Canada
had decided to
you know strike passage out outpost or something like I think
that >> Trump aside the question really comes down to like
did Iranians ask for bombs to be dropped on Iran because they
want to try and overthrow the government. That's really the even
like Trump aside or Israel aside in terms of who's doing I don't
think Iranians care that it's America. That's just who is an
option and who's there and obviously also who's powerful right?
But like they weren't sitting there like I really need the United
States to do this. It's just like oh you guys are like you might
come here or you're paying attention whatever it is please help
help. They were begging for anyone not like >> they were
happy that especially like a lot of a lot of women at least um
you know a lot of the videos that at least are circulating people
are
a lot of women who were saying that like oh my god they hit they
hit his palace like oh my god you know >> and they're like
>> crying and laughing and like having this insane emotional
moment of like oh my god the dictator's gone. >> women's
rights especially
especially have been really like there's biometric surveillance.
There's it's it's insane right? Like the the Ministry of Virtue
and Vice is like mass and mini protests and and there was no
international like intervention right? >> Yeah. It's like
oh we condemn killing your own people. It's like all right cool.
Keep condemning us to years of being killed.
People so they don't kill virgins. We have to the prisoner first.
And also bro I mentioned that um the Shah raised the age of consent
to 18 which is like based in that region and then immediately
after like in 79 immediately bro was like nah, nine. And then
in like 2004, they up to 13. It's like, guys, you're bro, bro.
They're like, you can't
Nine-year-olds can get It's like it is crazy the shift from uh
you know, having human rights to being under, you know, the bed
sheets as they call them. >> They're like insane or is
that just them saying that like we're taking the number from
the religious text?
>> Taking what number? >> Is that them like we want
to outlaw the marriage of nine-year-olds or is it like they're
just taking the number from the religious text? >> That
probably was what their reference point of reference is uh Muhammad.
And then they just like maybe the international community was
like, nine's crazy. And they're like, oh, Japan is 14. I'll go
for a 13. It's like, okay,
>> We have to be more [__] up than the >> Even
in parts of the US, right? You can As long as you're married
to
>> someone who's 13, yeah.
>> What Wait, you >> I think there's still states.
Alabama,
>> Yeah, definitely. So, they're definitely are still in
>> Oh, okay. I I believe that with a handful of those in
Yeah, that's definitely That's archaic as [__] You
should not be able to marry until like, I don't know. I want
to say 18 at least, >> 18? 18 would be good. I mean, Saudi
Arabia also um you know, uh I'm not an MBS fan, but um yeah,
yeah. Or or a Saudi fan really at all, but uh they recently also
made the um made the the minimum age 18 because similar kind
of thing. Um >> Oh, it's good they're at least They're
like It's like just like I was saying. They're at least being
pressured by the West to like, you know, shift to something civilized
so we can just like not have problems and we can we can this
so we can travel, we can have all >> It's difficult, though,
cuz I think there's um obviously there is a a total double standard
when it comes to um the Gulf allies cuz all of them are like
Saudi Arabia,
um Qatar, and um and the UAE. Like all three have basically like
forced labor um or some form of coerced labor. Some might call
that uh slavery. >> yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Indentured servitude
is another [laughter] type of >> You're trapped. >> You
know, but we do always hear about, you know, when small things
go right. It's like, "Oh, look at this very uh >> now.
Isn't that cute?" Yeah, yeah. It's like, "Oh, you don't need
permission to go travel?" Oh, wow. >> Don't look at the
political purge that he did behind that. Those small little changes,
but yeah. Um No, it's I don't know. There's uh I understand any
argument.
>> I definitely don't love that, by the way. I'm not like,
"Oh, yes. How do you guys awesome?" I'm yeah. Yeah.
>> I'm sorry. I didn't mean to cut you off there. You're
about to >> reflect on that.
No, I uh I I worry about Israel's involvement anytime when it
comes to uh just at the very like obviously within the the Levant,
but also it's like >> Just hold that Hold that. Could you
Are you in the presentation, Maywand? Are you in the presentation
right now? >> We've got uh You just said you were worried
about Israel's involvement. I need to take a quick look at this
video. Okay? It's a
very interesting video. Hold on.
I said I get Sorry. I was a stupid joke to pause for. Okay, whatever.
It's fine. >> Wait, did Kyle post that? Oh, no. Okay. >> know
who posted it. It's some some random guy. I'm sorry. >> People
just said it's the funniest video of the whole war because you
see I don't know if this is Jerusalem or >> the guy running
by. [laughter] >> if this is Jerusalem or but it's the
guy running by. Like it's the Orthodox guy running by and >> He
bolts. >> I was surprised by sirens. That's um >> Don't
beat.
>> Yeah. Well, and it it is crazy. Like anytime something
Anytime one of those missiles gets through, I think um cuz while
like obviously Hamas rockets are a totally different thing even
Hezbollah's like um abilities, right? Are are somewhat
Not not like as much, you know, I'm sure as Israel would like,
but
by comparison Iran has had maybe a military has
missile production has stuff.
So anytime it gets through like
you know, people people end up dying.
It would be great if Israel could just like uh enforce and provide
the Iron Dome for the West Bank. There's going to be some kind
of um claim to that territory. It's just very interesting to
me that it's like they're not allowed to build shelters
>> and everything else or have the Iron
But yeah, I don't I don't know.
Cuz it's >> you were saying that you have a like a concern
with Israel being involved. Is it just like a kind of like overall
they don't have a clean enough record that you can kind of like
>> idea about Iran at all. And it's not just Iran that's
like that.
Like there's obviously intelligence gathering, but in terms of
like a cultural understanding in terms of uh just like the region.
>> though. I can't >> No, I think that video was
AI. I think that video was AI. >> I Googled to see if Ken
can bro I mean again, maybe I just it says yes, but no. >> We
should pull it up cuz I I believe it was AI. Let me see. >> I
literally I literally thought I was like is it just AI translated
cuz it's like his low voice, but it would have to either be that
he's >> terms of Israel literally says
literally says in AI video Netanyahu tells Iranians in Persian
in Persian to unite and rise up against the empire the
>> Yeah. Today in AI video Netanyahu does >> Epic
epic I love that last time I Googled it it was like, yes, Benjamin
Netanyahu actually is capable of that. it's like
Now I Google again and it's like AI generated, not actually recording.
>> Oh my god, this technology freaks me the [__]
out. >> Yeah, it's that's that's my beat. And then you
know what's about it is like you'll see something in like the
Epstein files or you see something like this, you're like, all
right, let me just go see if like whatever Grok, Google, you
can at least amalgamate enough checks to be like, is this confirmed
as
>> No, no, no, no, but they just give you the sources for
the thing. You have to click through. You do have to click >> Yeah,
yeah, yeah, no, for sure, for sure. I've I you can literally
depending on the context, I can literally tell that it's wrong
and I'm like, uh, don't you mean this or like ask the question
again, it's like, yeah,
you definitely need to dig into like really get deep. But with
this I just it was a kind of an in passing thing where I was
like, oh, what the [__] Says yes, cool. I didn't
need to like super fact-check it. I didn't care to that degree,
but true. I that's good to know that that's not so I don't repeat
that cuz it's not true.
I'm glad I brought that up with you. >> So the question
was, do you what's your concerns about Israel being involved?
>> Yeah, I I don't think in terms of like regional awareness
because the other thing
going to take my minute to >> talk a little bit about what's
happening with Iran's neighbor, which is Afghanistan right now.
Um the Israel doing all of this stuff generally speaking like
they'll go in and kill all of the political elite in a cabinet
with I mean the US also
greenlit that, which is insane to me.
Just like in terms of a like, okay, well, we'll do a decapitation
strike and it's like okay, it's not this isn't that kind of situation
where if you kill all the leaders they the people underneath
them don't know what to do. They literally built the IRGC and
everything else, their political system
on the basis of knowing
Like having the contingency plan to the contingency >> They're
honestly probably like just shocked based on what I've heard
about how they set up this system. They're probably shocked that
Khamenei got to like almost 80 or sorry, over 80 years old. They're
probably just sitting there like, "How the [__] did
this go so long? We thought We thought we were going to be under
attack all the time."
>> And the fact that he was that old, you know for sure
they've been like planning what's next, so there were people
lined up. It wasn't I mean, that who was going to be the supreme
leader is a different question that's of like, I don't know when
that could have been decided if he appointed someone, but it's
like a whatever. But in terms of just in general, there's like
layers of command for sure. And uh
whatever, you can see the foreign minister was like almost crying.
He's like, "I don't know why America insists on attacking through
negotiations."
>> Cuz he's also the head of of the like the largest uh
sect of Shia Islam, like >> The supreme leader, right?
>> Yeah, yeah. I mean, he is the the head of um or was
the head of the Twelvers, like the um >> just like already
like a you know, say what you want about the Sunnis and a lot
of the um um that their extremists get up to, you Um totally
understandable, but um like in terms [clears throat] of an esca
an eschatological
like apocalypse-minded
um sect of any religion of which the Twelvers believe like there's
going to be like the end of the world uh precipitated by some
very specific events which look a lot like the head of my religion
was just killed. Um there was just like >> The end of days
is coming. >> There There Exactly, right? So, all of a
sudden you have a lot of like 250 million people around the world
whose like religious figurehead just
was killed um by Israel, which is already like part of their
religious uh apocalypse involves exactly that. It's like the
will cause problems. Um so, all of this is happening and so Karachi
explodes.
Um Baghdad explodes. Like all of these things are happening and
Israel's just "Oh, we don't know who's going to be the leader.
Maybe it'll be this Laraji guy." Um and Laraji's like, "No, like
death to America. Death to Israel." Um and glory to Islam. Like
it's it's just So there's no regional awareness. Um there's no
understanding at all. Um and there's not um any indication to
me that there's someone in Israel's uh war cabinet or the coalition
government that cares. Um and so I I don't think that's a good
>> it's more a question of caring than knowing cuz I feel
like he just even from proximity and his interest and concern
and just for so long he you know it's a broken record where he's
talking about the nukes. Again, whether it's just sourced from
intelligence or what, I feel like he is at least aware but not
uh you know >> Maybe aware of the >> the information
and and like you said doesn't care. That's that's fair for sure.
I just I feel like he is at least aware. It would be it would
be shocking >> of how it might impact Israel but he doesn't
give a [__] about how it impacts >> Give a
[__] is a different question. Give a [__]
but just in terms of understanding
uh what I was saying I think he understands it but I agree with
you on him not caring. I'm not saying he's like none of this
is coming from the bottom of anyone's heart. It's just like a
>> their interest happened to create a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity for people who've been trapped for 47 47 years. All
right? It's just
I don't know if that's what they're doing either. Right? I don't
think that
uh what Israel is is doing. I don't I don't think it has anything
to do with the people >> No, that's what I'm saying. That's
what I'm saying. It's not about he's not it's not like that's
what I mean about it not coming from the bottom of his heart.
They have their own intentions. They're like the US and Israel
is going to do what they're going to do but the the moment of
like opportunity that the Iranian people have been basically
uh needing or looking for. Again, it could end up going terrible.
I'm I'm the hopium optimist here, but this like like he said,
something has to give. There would never be And that's what I
was asking Jessica earlier. How do you change dictatorship regime
without military force? It You need military force. You could
say you need more like ground boots on the ground, but the So,
that's what I mean by the external bombs being the opening a
doorway for opportunity.
>> Well, in in
short, it like obviously military
aspect can uh cause regime change. Like, sure, but in 1978,
there was a popular movement um that began and it realistically
the the Iranian people
understand
and know. That's why they have been protesting. That's why
in terms of like there in December there were a bunch of reformist
politicians. One of them was uh a pretty famous
uh like judge basically like a jurist.
he was believe executed just like latently like killed by Basij.
But so, all of this is happening >> the war, but go on.
Yeah, yeah. >> No, no. He's being basically like a reformist
politician >> Oh, right. Because yeah, you can't reform
that you know, God's word. So, get out of here. You're you're
ripped. >> No, no. I mean, he was still he was still like
a you know, a devout Muslim, but like
against what the government is doing.
That's what I mean. That's what I mean. >> people in the
last like in the last 2 months that that have been killed and
like you see the amount of executions of people protesting escalating
again.
>> Throughout like literally even as bombs are falling,
they executed four people
So, all of this is still happening, right? Um I guess like
I don't know. >> What question for you then actually cuz
you just laid something out for me that like gives me the the
perfect question
you were saying in 78 79 there was massive support for this revolution
or like for that shift in the political
nonviolent protest movement in 1978
more than 1979
but yeah, like people people
>> Yeah, because I mean the exact same kind of thing was
happening, right? Like the people were protesting protesters
were being killed and then on the 40th day I mean
got people triggered was a certain like massacre in a protest.
And also there's the whole you know about the like the theater
that got lit on fire and then it turns out it was like probably
a
whatever like false flag or red herring like basically the the
Islamists did that to try and be like look the
you know, the Shah burned a theater with people alive in there.
>> I think both people yeah, both both sides blame the
other it's kind of so I guess we're going to yeah. >> Think
about the not not in the consequential but maybe undeterminable.
>> One last question then I'm going to move on. I do want
to move on with the content.
>> My last thing there was if you're saying like they had
massive support in the 78 but you agree that over 89% of people
want a democratic election system is that not then mean that
there is that massive support right
but they're literally incapable because of the violent force.
>> happening in the last uh not even 3 months but go back
to like at least 2022 right with Masa There have been [clears throat]
and there were the exact same thing so people going in mourning
on the 40th day those protests those protest funerals were then
being cracked down on like 1978 is almost like a carbon copy
to what we were seeing in December January
you know, and part of February and it's like I'm worried that
by the US and Israel doing what they're doing
not only have they um
I think it's possibly sped up a a natural progression
what was going to happen but I it you
more people would have obviously died. Um it would have taken
longer. It would not have been >> That right there is the
key point. It's the trolley problem is legitimately like this
this whole thing comes down to a trolley problem. It is yes,
things are going to get worse before they get better and it's
going to be a insane time and I have the luxury of not being
in the line of fire, but the other option is you stay you pray
that like ah maybe these Islamists will like kind of one day
be cool and a tens of thousands of people are going to get killed
as you wait for this like and that's even more wishful than what
I think as my my and I know I'm wishful but like the idea that
they're going to suddenly become not crazy is like I I feel like
not born out by the >> you can overthrow a government without
influence um >> Would you but do you think that they can
with this?
Uh yeah, but that was when the
That was before the dictatorship that is like as oppressive as
uh this one cuz if if the Shah was as oppressive he would have
just said no everyone keep machine gunning them down like do
not let them ever rise up and which is what they currently do.
So it's Uh I agree with you that you can have non-violent revolutions,
but I don't think in the context of Iran that that is feasible.
Um also sorry I just got I'm going to I don't mean I I I'll I'll
keep responding and I don't want to keep you if you were trying
to cut the convo, so.
>> We can continue this convo offline. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. >> But I do want to just um ask my one really quickly.
My prediction here is that what Iran's actually doing with these
other strikes they're doing to other people in the region I think
they struck in a uh Saudi oil field. I think they're just going
to basically be like, "Actually, you're going to [__]
up the entire world economy attacking us? We're going to keep
hitting like stuff that's not really protected, stuff that's
like economic infrastructure in the Middle
And every one of your Gulf partners is going to tell you to get
out of here. Yeah, yeah, so they're just going to make it as
expensive as possible to everybody else in the planet for America
to continue helping Israel do this. And then they're going to
>> actually hit an oil field?
>> Yeah, I don't uh if they've actually hit an oil field
um in Saudi Arabia, we're about to see Saudi Arabia probably
go in uh with the military and
unfortunately, it's going to >> Saudi boots on the ground?
>> Ooh, let's go. Let's go. Calling the reinforcements.
Yo, you need to have France send a carrier out. >> If it's
actually if they if they struck an oil field um
>> That's what I've been reading, but I don't know for
sure.
Yeah, I'll I'll I'll take a look cuz I that that would be a very
bad development. Um
Unwise. I would It's not what I would >> I do agree though,
Jessica. They are basically trying to make this as like um poisonous
for the for America on a global scale, like make everyone hate
them and be mad that they decided to like initiate this action.
I do think that's their intention with like spraying missiles
in every direction. >> Well, they would They They've definitely
been trying to um
hit the things that the Gulf cares about um to make them kick
out the Americans or at least like buy them enough time of being
you know, survive longer than the stockpiles of of munitions
or whatever that the Americans have, but um Yeah, hitting hitting
hitting the Saudis is probably not the thing that's going can
do it.
>> Has anyone seen somebody talking about this yet? It's
the Saudi Aramco oil field that got hit. It says Iranian drones.
I've not seen the drones landing. I've seen multiple people talking
about this, and I've seen multiple videos. So, I'm not but I'm
not seeing like the main people like the main accounts talking
about it, which is weird. Like I'm seeing a lot of I'm seeing
a lot of accounts posting videos
that seem to be the case. I'm going to go to the FaZe Tox Discord
and just see if I can find it here. >> Yeah, yeah.
>> I'm seeing refinery [clears throat] shuts down after
small fire
from apparent drone strike, Economic Times.
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry. My one I had like one
>> Yeah, that's Reuters. Reuters Reuters
>> You mean like they have the same title, I'm assuming,
cuz I I clicked on a different thing, but I could just be the
>> Saudi Saudi Aramco shuts Ras Tanura refinery after drone
drone strike. My god, if I can pronounce anything today.
>> Epic Ayatollah Penguin, by the way. That's great.
>> Oh my god, I love Top Bronson W. Yeah. >> The
title of this from Top Bronson was Shah. That is the Shah outfit.
I don't think that's the Shah outfit, but it's a >> Not
quite, but you know. >> Ayatollah logistical. >> It's
all good. It's okay. >> Sorry. My one can I ask like or
I guess just can I ask my one one last quick question or like
>> Yeah, go. >> one and a half person. Uh basically,
do you What is your Do you Okay. The the bombing of the girl
school, do you think it was for sure Israel? Are you waiting
for confirmation from some sort of whatever >> Oh, oh I
have Yeah, I have I have no no doubt that they hit the school.
Um I think all of the reporting that I've seen has >> That Israel
did it or that it was hit in >> Yeah, no no. Uh they absolutely
did. Yeah. I I have no no question about that. Um it it does
sound like they did >> from Iran?
>> No, no. Um I don't I don't trust anything that Tasnim
or or [laughter] IRNA or any of the >> the area, right?
>> Yeah, yeah. I don't And so I don't I don't trust anything
that Iranian state media says unless it's like specifically confirming
deaths. Um similarly, I don't trust anything that >> be
a Even that could be a smoke [laughter] screen so that he can
escape,
Um When they first said Khamenei's dead, I was like I don't know
if that's true. He could just be hiding and no one can claim
that so he can get out of there, right? But
the bombs started falling like they somebody had reported that
and so I for an entire day I was like that's I'm not listening
to like Khan news or N12
>> The reason I ask is
I mean obviously I'm waiting for some sort of external verification
to show like what's the path of the missile that landed there
and basically to get some sort of hard verification. But my initial
response and thought is you know, a country that doesn't like
women and doesn't mind killing its own people and and a country
that really wants to make the US look bad right now and Israel
and that's why they're attacking all these other countries like
just let's just say it's like a super high chance that Iran bombed
their own [__] >> No, I don't I don't think
I don't think at all. >> It's really out of character for
Israel to bomb a school. >> Yeah, exactly. I I have seen
with my own two eyes Israel >> I get you. I get you. I
understand I understand what you're saying. But those are the
whole situation with the you know, human shields and building
bases and blah blah blah blah blah. Sure, sure, sure. That's
>> I think they're going with the same excuse here to be
honest with you. >> Here's my Here's my thought or my response
to that. is in a in a mission where they have such precise missiles
they can get people in like individual apartment buildings on
the whatever 10th floor or some [__] >> Why
would they waste
Yeah, why would they waste missiles on like let's just get a
100 Persian kids over in the corner for It's like it's just It's
like a ex- It's such an extra unnecessary thing that you I feel
like you in a way have to By the way, that that doesn't rule
out that it was an accident that they were like looking for a
like the military base and the whatever wrong thing was targeted.
That I'm not saying it's impossible that they did it. But in
terms of intentionality,
it just seems like you kind of have to just kind of like believe
that they're evil in a way that you again, pattern recognition,
and fine. I get what you're saying with other places, but it
doesn't there's no logic for me that it would even be worth it
for them to waste a missile on that. You know what I'm
That's where my That's where my thought process goes. >> Well,
I definitely Yeah, there's definitely no military
um >> Yeah, and it actually makes And it specifically makes
them look terrible, right? If it's like, "Oh, they can now prove
that we bombed a kids' school instead of just hitting so It's
like It literally works against them to do it. Just like, "How
much do you hate little Persian girls?" I don't I feel like it
Maybe he just He's got bigger goals, you know what I'm saying?
I get it. You're like, "Oh, he's he's evil, blah blah blah."
But like it We're talking about a a global scale intense war
right now. The idea of like a 100 >> they were already
did like daytime
strikes, right? So that should have been part of any any calculation
that they were doing
is that people would be out and about doing their normal thing.
They specifically chose the daytime in order to  get a
surprise advantage, right? So they they were striking in the
daytime when they knew civilians would be at the height of walking
around and and doing stuff. >> Do you think BB has really
learned Farsi if he's willing to okay strikes on little girls?
Be real. Nice. Nice. Nice. Nice. But no, legitimately, the I
understand it was during the day, but when you say out and about,
this wasn't like people in the streets got hit. It was the building
itself that got hit. >> of of little girls at school, yeah.
>> All right, so that's what I'm saying is
why It's not a question of like yes, they did it during the day
because they could target and specifically kill the the you know,
political leaders and the people that were the real targets.
Why it's like "Ah, guys, we you know, side project, B plot. You
over there, make sure you kill those 100 girls." It's just You
kind of have to make it up is really the is what I'm getting
at. I have one last question for you and then I I don't want
to cut Oh, sorry, go on. I don't want to cut you off for a response,
but I just >> No, I I I just I don't I don't know if it
needs to be intentional for me to um >> Oh, if it was if
it's a fact even as an accident, if it's a fact, yes, I blame
them and hold them responsible 100% 100%. I'm just waiting for
the confirmation and I'm telling you where my biased skepticisms
or whatever are. But that doesn't exonerate them even if it was
like oh it was an accident you didn't mean to kill them. It's
like well be better at your job then. Don't be don't miss right?
So I'm with you 100%. It's not it doesn't make it okay. It's
just a question of who really did it and then when we know that
we can make our final judgment. My last question um We aside
from those 100 casualties or approximately 100 those girls at
the school have you seen reports of other civilian casualties
that are not um the political targets?
>> Yeah so there there is limited reporting
in terms of uh like an agency that um I was at least checking
I I put it in the um the research [clears throat] channel but
I I can share it uh to the I don't know I'll I'll put it somewhere
um but HRANA um H R A N A um put out like daily um normally again
they're like a prison advocacy and execution
monitor um but during the protests and it looks like they're
starting again for this uh this war period they have been collecting
where they can
um but there's no internet right now um and [clears throat] in
terms of uh like
there's like we don't have
when you said they were doing it again were you referring to
protesters being killed by like IRGC?
um it was >> No no um >> I I mis- I misheard something
there I was trying to get a
were [clears throat] responding militarily to some of the the
protests especially in um Mashhad but uh no I was talking about
HRANA counting deaths but yeah. >> Right but okay so to
clarify I meant civilian casualties from like American or Israeli
bombs not just total deaths that are happening if if it's Basij
killing it that's a falls into the killing themselves part. >> um
in terms of what you said >> seen is the kids school that's
the only one thing I've heard. I'm I'm about 24 hours out of
date though, so I like I haven't seen what >> Yeah, so
Hirana
Hirana are doing some of the calculations,
um but information is limited. I think at least 300 300 and something
people, but um yeah, we we won't have a good picture >> And
this is an estimate on civilians, not political targets, right?
>> confirmed
civilians, yeah. In in terms of yeah. Yeah, cuz they they try
to only report specifically on confirmed and sometimes they they'll
include a secondary number as an estimate of reported but not
confirmed yet. >> Yeah, yeah. I just wanted to make sure
that it's specific cuz if it's like uh you know, they got you
know, 100 political targets, it's like that's obviously the intention.
The concern is how many more people than those like 100 girls.
And again, we talked about this before. People can all be triggered
like, "Oh my god, a school." But it's again the trolley problem.
We're talking about 32,000 plus people getting mowed down. There's
casualties in war. And again, a luxury a luxury of freedom >> Like
if you if you're going to if you're going to make this argument,
why don't you just make the argument instead of like asking if
it's happening and then justifying it anyway? Like I it it just
feels really weird like asking if it's happening >> I asked
her that out of genuine curiosity.
I asked her I just wanted to know is there more of that thing
happening? That's literally that I was just asking her cuz she
seems informed and I haven't looked up like and I was googling
it up >> it feels it feels super I get super frustrated
when I see that when it's like I I feel like people are asking
cuz they like it would change something, but it doesn't really
change anything. >> Oh, no. Sorry. To be clear, I wasn't
trying to ask it in a way that yeah, I wasn't trying to play
a game there or like do some weird black [__] with
that um like rhetorically. It was just regardless I think the
overall concept
I get you. People are like annoying with debate and certain
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. No, totally. And >> that it wasn't
happening, right? But then you're like, well, even if it is happening.
Like you're you're saying it cuz you're hoping it wasn't happening
that people are like blowing it out of proportion. And then >> No,
no, no, no. I I believe those women got killed or the the kids
got killed and I wish that didn't happen, obviously. I don't
want a single civilian casualty. I don't That's like I don't
want any of the There's three confirmed soldiers dead. None of
that is >> I'm saying that you were basically you'd already
it wouldn't have changed your thoughts on it at all, but you
asked about it cuz you hoped it could be something you could
talk about to like get people on the other side of the issue
and then you found out it wasn't, but it really That's why you're
asking about it cuz you were hoping it would get disproved. get
disproved. >> I understand that you think that. I >> But
we're not saying something different. We're not saying something
>> I feel like we are cuz I feel like you're putting an
intention of like I would shift it or I'm trying to like convince
the audience about something. That was I wanted the information
for me because I don't have an updated number beyond the school
and because that's the only story I've heard. I would I wanted
to know like were more apartments getting hit? Like was there
other like big civilian tragedies happening from the bombs? >> Yeah,
several several hospitals
have have sustained damage. I don't I don't know if there's been
a like a direct hit on any of those hospitals, but because they
are focusing most of the military strikes on Tehran, it's it's
like you know, Gandhi Hospital, I think like the front of it
basically was like gone, but
from what I know nobody has died at least from any strike on
a hospital directly, but there are injuries,
but yeah, they the the information's incomplete right now.
I put the link to the Iran report from
It just in content links as well.
>> Yeah. But yeah, yeah, I'll hop off cuz I
J Steel OK wants to go back to content, so Yeah, it's good talking
to you. >> Yeah, you too. It was a pleasure. >> Yeah,
maybe maybe. But I I'm at technically at the end of my stream.
I just know I'm going to have like a mutiny if I actually just
leave right now. So >> people are like >> Uh if I
could just say one last word to the people in chat that are uh
bunch of [__] queers. Um suck my And yeah, just go.
I hope that that was a better quality conversation even if we
disagree, whatever, agree, disagree, that's okay. But um yeah,
I just wanted that to be a actual legitimate attempt to like
cut through ideas.
>> it was very very much like talking to like a maga person.
>> No, no. I You can You can feel You can You can emotionally
You can You can hate my opinions, but I'm saying like in terms
of like genuinely just trying to >> No, I I I genuinely
was like trying to logically talk through things and you were
basically like I have hopium and there's going to be a miracle.
It's like that's what it's like talking to a Trump supporter.
When they have no logical reason to believe something will happen
and I'm just saying like give me anything. You're like, "Well,
conversations with people who share my exact opinions." I'm like,
"Okay." >> No, I had other examples, but I get you. So
So your your issue is not the actual like whatever. I I I mean
like there's no like debate >> My problem is if you like
wanted to talk about how awesome Reza Pahlavi is and I'm fine
with that, but that's like immaterial to like the actual core
questions on whether or not this is a good move to do for anybody
in the United States or
>> And you even You even stated that it's not if that actually
is relevant to there being an on-the-ground rebellion of a large
majority. That's why I was talking about it because it's relevant
in that way and because I've seen signs that indicate to me there
is a conversation in the background, which is not being explicitly
said and endorsed by Trump. So it's not really irrelevant even
if you think I'm unreasonable for thinking that could happen.
Um Yeah,
I mean you're goofy too if that's your >> Basically said
tea leaves. You basically said tea leaves and >> Uh It's
like >> Bro, everything's tea leaves. >> sell this
to people. That would help >> Everything is tea leaves
for everyone until this is concluded. No one knows how this is
going to end up. When I say tea leaves, I'm saying like I'm just
being humble to the fact that like obviously no one has factual
information of how this will end up in whatever 3 months or 3
years. That's what I mean when I say tea leaves. And also certain
amount of like okay, you have to make inferences from this or
an extrapolation from that. And
these things are not all being given to us explicitly. So there
is a certain amount of like contemplating
the larger picture that you have to do. And yeah, fair enough
if you don't want to make some of those leaps or like don't have
the sources of information to make those leaps. But yeah, it's
uh whatever. If you think it's just like >> just when we
went when we went through like the the idea of like the logistics
of this to actually overthrow this government, there's nothing
logistically that like supports the idea that this will happen.
Um it feels like borderline impossible, but I again, um
>> You're just assuming I'm wrong about the the boots on
the ground of the nation thing, right? Of like the popular uprising?
Cuz you said that that feels the spot on the boots on the ground,
which is the necessary thing. >> for people to be for those
people to be coordinated, what would have to happen is for them
to have like a long time to come together and congregate and
and figure out like a network of people that they could call
on, right? If that's been going on long enough, I believe they
would get infiltrated fairly easily and disrupted.
>> All right. I mean yeah, it's like we are just are agreeing
to disagree. I think you're I I don't think that's unreasonable,
but I think you're wrong. You think I'm not even engaging honestly
because you think what I believe is so unlikely that it like
is not even like a valid >> I think it's just not based
on reality.
>> That's again, your perspective. We will see how it turns
out. And won't it be hilarious if I'm right? And won't it be
hilarious if I'm wrong? It's both ways. Either I'm or like that's
crazy. >> I'm asking you for you to give me like like some
reasoning you think this. You're just saying well, I've had I've
had discussions with people who really like the show. And I >> I'm
sure people who really like the show would say these are >> That's
not what I said. That's not what I said. I didn't say I had discussions
with people who like the show. I said there was very clear support
and you didn't want to pull up any of the last 2 months of the
things. We did end up getting the one with the someone dropped
a link for like the 350,000, but there it's it's not from conversations
I've had. It's very obvious from 100% of protest footage that
has the lion and and sun flag that they are also pro Pahlavi.
So and with both inside and outside the country, they've been
saying Javid Shah Javid Shah, which means long live the king
like
return of Pahlavi. So it's not it's not just like oh I some people
told me that whatever and I I do feel like you're being dishonest
and dismissing it. >> How does that compare to your 91%
want
>> It's he's referred to as the crown prince. It's not
come be the ruler king. It's return it's they want the Shah and
Shah, the king of kings was his dad. And he was the prince that
is now technically would be, you know, have ascended to king.
It's not saying we want him to come be our king ruler. It's saying
we want the Pahlavi dynasty to return and then we'll create our
secular democracy under that. Yeah, you just whatever. You like
kind of in some way you call it disingenuous but you really just
dismiss things as if you know. Yeah, you really I was going to
say this honestly, you speak about things like you know so much
when you admitted you don't know [__] about Iran
before you didn't cover it for the last 2 months and you come
with these super adamant like incredulous opinions and be honest,
it really seems like you're misplaying this. >> of my opinions
based on the attitude of the people?
>> No, your opinion is completely contrast against the
opinion of the people, which is why it's like very jarring and
>> you I'm literally asking you to explain to me. So I'm
giving you a logical like a progression here. So I think there
if there were a large on the ground movement of people who were
organized in any way that that would be easy to infiltrate. Therefore
it's unlikely to believe is unlikely and I do not believe that
there is a large force that could rise up in any coordinated
way. I believe you would need a large coordinated force to overthrow
the government. Therefore, I do not believe the government will
be overthrown.
>> Got you. Objection speculation.
Logical, but speculative.
That's why we're both we're both just presenting our speculations.
Uh that it is objective
absolute fact that it would then be infiltrated and not have
any way
precipitating any in any fashion. I get what you're saying. I'm
not saying that's illogical. I'm not saying that's unreasonable
or like not couldn't probably happen or whatever the [__]
I'm saying it doesn't mean that it is absolutely the fact and
that doesn't completely negate the chance of that existing. So
no, it's not a 100% unreasonable thing. It's a low probability
thing in a difficult
>> that there's a lot of people who are very upset about
the regime. I don't disagree with that. >> Uh-huh. But
you do disagree that a lot of people want the Pahlavi guy to
come to do a >> rise up against this regime. >> to
be the Okay. Yeah, and so we just disagree, but you do not have
any factual information. You again also just talking other people
and apparently not really looking into like much of the footage
enough to end up having [__] opinions. Actual [__]
uninformed opinions. And so yeah, like you could be making under
>> were massive? Did I discount that the protests were
massive? >> You discounted You discounted the message of
the protests en masse, which is a consistent 100%
like that through line goes all the way from the beginning of
January is that people inside and outside of the country have
been >> The Shah is coming back. >> calling for this
guy's name. Yeah, so you guys just do that incredulous thing
where you're like, "Oh yeah, dude. Yeah, totally. Oh, no. You're
going to get [__] or you know, there's going to be
a revolution. Good one, buddy." And it's >> $500. Shah
doesn't set foot in that country for the next decade.
Sorry, that's $500. >> money on anything, but I I've come
out here and put my like voice and whatever it is on the line
for it that you know, and all of Jack can think I'm a total piece
of [__] in the because of my ice takes or my hot
takes. >> of [__] because I think you are emotional
about this because you dislike the because you were raised in
a culture that really hates the Islamic Republic. Justifiably
so. Your your family clearly left for a reason, right?
>> You don't like authoritarian dictatorships that are
like theocracies that crack down on the rights of everybody around
you. We all hate >> I feel like I feel like everyone agrees
with that. >> I'm arguing that I love Khomeini or >> No.
No. That's why No, no, not at all. It's not It's not that that
annoys me. It's the everything kind of just going back to Israel
and in a way It's actually it's very specifically the trying
to state things as if you know the message of the protest of
the masses when it does not line up whatsoever with what I have
clearly been glued to for the last few months. >> I'm saying
I do not believe there's popular support for the Shah to return
to Iran. >> Right. And I'm telling you the only way you
could think that is if you haven't been paying attention for
the last 2 months. That is the only way you could think that.
>> do you so many credible people who follow this region
>> Who? Laugh and scoff? >> So, Joanna for one, but
also like anytime I've been watching I've watched I've watched
this on Drop site, I've watched this on Al Jazeera before. I've
seen multiple people laughing at this. So, I asked you, can you
give me a credible expert on the region who believes that the
Shah has widespread support? And you said, "No, I can't do that."
>> No, I said I can >> I will pull that video up.
I will pull that video up. Yeah, you said So, you said I don't
want to do that now. >> Yeah, I'll I'll search for it if
you want to Yeah, for sure. If you want to do whatever like show
the audience It's like to to fill the time, obviously. Do whatever
you need to do to entertain and I'll keep you there. >> I
probably I'm going to let you go, but I'll watch the video. I'll
bring you back in if you want to watch the video together. >> Sure,
sure, sure, yeah. No sweat. That's legit. That's legit.
>> Yeah, I'll I'll 100% provide that. For sure. No sweat.
All right. Cheers. Good talk, yo. >> Yep. Bye.
>> Peace out.